jeff why do you teach writing
i've been fascinated with
the technique of writing ever since i
got into it well
really it started in prep school when i
had
three good english teachers in a row and
i always
responded in a course if i liked the
teacher if i didn't like the teacher i
wouldn't perform if i did
i would go for it and we had these
one teacher was a scottish
fellow who spent three months reading
macbeth to us
and translated translated it all
and translated the you know the
the ambient world of shakespeare to help
make more sense of it
and he would read a few lines of macbeth
and then talk for 45 minutes about what
was going on and
end up at the end of that talk about how
in the old west the idea that you could
pull out your revolver and shoot
somebody's gun out of their hand
he said that's so unrealistic because
you could put one of those
pistols in a vice and never hit the same
spot twice
so that would be like just the level of
you know interesting material that i was
being exposed to and i learned how to
write there write essays and stuff like
that
so that when i ran into a fellow in
vermont who was a playwright and he
offered to
teach a friend of mine playwriting i
asked if i could jump in on that
he taught us the basics of aristotle and
he gave us
these two books to read and
i sat down and read them for three years
uh that's pretty much all i did trying
to
at first because i was a painter before
that so i came into playwriting
knowing nothing and knowing that i knew
nothing so
it makes it easier to learn if you don't
already think you know it
and this fellow william thompson price
was he was a
script doctor two broadway producers
around 1910
um he helped revise every play that this
uh producer david belasco produced on
broadway he's quite famous
and so many people were coming to him
asking
for help with their scripts and with the
tools he created
for playwriting technique that he
started the first school of playwriting
ever
and uh he had 28 students 24 of them had
hits on broadway
and he wrote this one book in 1908
which is the one i sat down and started
reading
at first i couldn't understand it it was
really dense and complex but i kept
working my way through it
and he kept checking in
as a teacher saying you have to
understand what i just explained
otherwise you should just forget the
whole thing because this is key
so and i would i would stop and he'd go
stop and think about it and
see if you understand it and at first i
was like
i really don't understand it at all so i
go back and reread it
and i still didn't understand it because
it was it's like when einstein said when
he first started studying
uh theoretical physics
the stuff that he specialized in he was
stupefied by it for the first two years
it was so complex that he was stupefied
by it this material is obviously
you know way easier than that but the
degree of complexity
was still a lot for me and so
i read price's book and then his
students book
and then i read price's book again on
his students book again
and after a while i got to where i was
understanding what they were talking
about but felt like i still couldn't use
it
and so when i started
teaching people i did hands-on training
i did small groups
maximum six people each person had to
bring their own story that they were
working on so i could get them
actually using the tool instead of them
just listening to me talk about it
because i understood that you could get
to a place where you understand it
and still not be able to actually use it
so that's why i would work hands-on
with each person in the group and just
the science of it and the
art of it is has always been fascinating
and it's just
something that people have responded
well
to the know-how that i was giving them
and
it was stimulating and
and interesting so i've just remained
fascinated by it
have you ever thought back to with those
three teachers
had they been teachers that maybe you
didn't necessarily
want to perform for or impress
or have like your work the trajectory of
what your life would have been
yeah no i wouldn't have been fascinated
with writing
i don't think it ever would have come up
i mean
i love to read and i love movies and
plays and
great novels and that's kind of thing
but as
a as something that i felt strongly
compelled to dive into
and gain a mastery of i don't know if it
would have been there how important is
it for you to have students
feel similar maybe you can disagree on
many things but at least they want to do
well for you
how how important is that and how does
one establish that
i'm not entirely sure partly because
by the time they seek out someone like
me they already have
some kind of passion for the material
now i may awaken in them
a deeper passion
as they see that they could
as they see that there's more perhaps
than they thought
there was to learn and that
because the way in which i teach is
is is
scientific in its own way because each
of the tools
has certain distinctions like to use the
tool properly you have to be able to
make certain distinctions
for instance like in dilemma consists of
two equally unacceptable alternatives so
there's real distinctions in that
so it's two on two painful choices
and for for it to be a real dilemma they
have to be equally unacceptable
because if you you could have two
unacceptable choices where do you want
to get burned by a match or do you want
to jump in the lava
those are both unacceptable but they're
nowhere near equal
but if you have to choose between you
know sacrificing your husband or your
son
to like you know a slave owner who's
going to take one or the other
you that's that when they're equal and
of magnitude
then it really paralyzes the protagonist
and
renders the material riveting to the
audience
so the distinctions are key for using
the tools
properly and so
once a student sees that
there's a real specificity to the use of
these tools and if you use them
properly and fully you can get
tremendous power
especially out of a story that has
promised but has not been performing for
them
so that the ability to
it's kind of like being a martial arts
teacher from one point of view
where somebody may have some fighting
skills
but you're able to go look you keep your
elbow up and they can you know there's
certain technical things that you can
show them that you can
turn them into a considerably better
fighter pretty quickly if they already
have some basic skills
by no by key distinctions and
observation
and just know-how
so that it's you know it's a uh
it's a process of giving students
genuine know-how
and once they see that
they really could master this stuff
if they apply themselves and they've
seen their script improve a lot
from working hands-on with me in the
class that that can really
give them a fire in the belly because
whereas before they just
wanted to write stories now they
understand the distinction between a
storyteller and a dramatist and that if
you're going to
turn us if you're going to adapt a story
for a theatrical presentation whether
that's a film
tv show theater that it has to be
the story has to be stage worthy it has
to be able to be performed by an actor
in such a way that it grips the audience
so there's a lot of
specificity to making a
theatrical presentation of a story work
in such a way that it really grips an
audience
and once they get a handle on
this is considerably different than
what i thought it was and that's only
true for some people some people come in
with a lot of knowledge already
and i'm just showing them a few more
tools but there but the tools are
powerful enough that they can see that
if they really apply themselves
and learn to use them fully and properly
that they'll
their scripts will tend to work and so
that can really
amplify somebody's passion
tell us about your cognitive
apprenticeship the cognitive
apprenticeship is
quite fascinating it was something that
i discovered
just as i was beginning to
um create this particular training
program
i had thought about it for a good couple
years
because i always taught in small
hands-on groups
and i didn't see how to teach bigger
groups because the material
is complex and sophisticated enough that
in my experience unless i got you doing
it on your script
that it was abstract enough so that even
if you listen to an explanation of it
then when you go home and try to do it
on your own partially formed script
you generally don't have enough know-how
and experience
and just
general knowledge and working know-how
to
to use it across a broad spectrum of
ideas
so i spent a couple years trying to
figure out how to teach larger groups
and in the process of that i also
studied the science of how
people learn and that has grown and
changed
tremendously in the last 100 years and
hugely in the last 50 years
they've figured out so much about the
science of how people learn
to the point where they even have people
in an mri
and they're doing experiments on them
teaching them things and seeing which
parts of their brain light up and all
that
so that they understand much more
completely
how people learn they've even figured
out
that in the process of acquiring an
expert skill
that the brain creates a neural network
specifically for the acquisition and
retention of that particular skill
and if you're and the more that you
practice it
with complete attention complete
attention
and strong intention that
this neural network you can picture it
like a dirt road which connects
two two sections of the brain
very close together and the signal
travels from one to the other
and the more you diligently practice
like if you're learning to be a baseball
pitcher
and you practice over and over and
really stay focused with a good coach
that that neural network gets enhanced
it literally grows and changes and what
they found is that
the brain does what's called myelination
it's a
it's a fatty coating that insulates
that neural network from outside chatter
so it gets more focused
and that myelination continues so that
neural network literally
gets broader and faster and so it turns
into an information superhighway where
it used to be a dirt road and
so the people that have substantial
expert skills
it's built into their brain and it will
never go away it does not
go away so like for instance when i was
a kid i did a lot of
games um like skittle bowl
which is a a thing on a ball and a chain
and you send it around and it comes in
and you're bowling
and i did that you know thousands of
times and i got quite good with the
motion
so that there was one game where it's
two
steel rods connected at one end and
there's a steel ball and you have to
squeeze
the rods together and that forces the
ball to go slightly uphill
and it's really hard to master because
the ball keeps falling through it's a
touch where you have to
you're letting it roll downhill slightly
and squeezing them together so it keeps
going up and let it
and you gradually work it up and i got
really good at that when i was like 12
or something i did it
constantly and i saw one in somebody's
house a couple years ago
i went up to i was like i used to be
able to do this and i tried it and on
the very first try i did it perfectly
this is like really really hard to do
and so it shows you like that
once it's really seated in your brain at
that level that it's permanent
in the process of studying this
fascinating material about the science
of learning and
and looking at how i taught because i
didn't want to teach the same way i did
i didn't find it effective enough to do
a 30 hour
intensive which is very much like fire
hose teaching where i'm just
hammering you with a complex array of
information that's not easy to retain
and i always felt dissatisfied like i
could do more i could do better
they could they could come away from my
training with
very substantial skills instead of some
sense of it and really excited about it
and so i pulled
a lot of interesting stuff together and
teaching techniques
and then a week before uh
lockdown hit i sat down and started
building this particular training
program full-time
and then covet hit and i had even more
time because i wasn't driving the kids
around and that kind of stuff
so i really focused and i found this
essay one of the one of the books on the
science of learning talked about
these people who did some interesting
stuff with the science of learning
i looked them up and found an essay they
had written
about cognitive apprenticeship which is
which is built upon a standard
apprenticeship which is how people learn
best you know working with a master to
become a shoemaker barrel maker that
kind of thing that's
been around for thousands of years
and so all of that is still there it's
still very much an apprenticeship
but the cognitive apprenticeship has to
do with
the cognitive skills that accompany some
sorts of training processes like for
instance
if you're apprenticing to a lawyer say
they wouldn't call it apprenticeship
these days but you're still studying
right with
people in the law sure there's lots of
stuff of like how you do things and what
you say in court and
and the technicalities of the law but so
much of it
is cognitive facility of how you think
so the process of how you think from one
point of view is everything
in in a in a skill set like that
so it was fascinating in that
as i'm trying to as i'm sitting down to
create this training program
and it's going to be a two-year training
program
for writers uh in the craft of the
dramatist
that i found this 30-page essay
and as i'm reading it i'm going like
this
is like to the t
exactly what i'm doing so it was like
finding you know a high performing
rocket fuel right when you're building a
rocket like
you didn't know you even needed it and
then somebody shows up with this stuff
and it changes everything
so i spent a month reading these 30 page
essay over and over again
read it once read it once yellow
highlight then went over that and pink
highlight and then
worked with that and typed up all the
highlighted things and
sorted them for prioritization and
categorization and
put them on three by five cards and like
okay i need to put this
into this part of training someone in
the craft or the dramatist and it really
consolidated and amplified
so much of what i was doing
and you know the the craft of the
dramatist is so much it's
it's more a way of thinking
than a set of rules it's the habits of
mind of a trained dramatist
is what i'm training people in and
that's
what it's always been but these people
were talking about exactly that the
habits of mind
that go along with teaching something
sophisticated to people
so it was a fully developed science
that through a couple years of hard work
i hit upon just at the right moment and
i really
built that into the course in every way
possible so that i was constantly
using what i had learned about the
science of
how people learn the science of
cognitive apprenticeship and the cu
and the science of training for
expertise
um i was always
using that to
change how i teach to the point where i
would
finish one lesson and be getting ready
to start another whole
tool and one of the things they talk
about
um i'm not sure if it was in cognitive
apprenticeship or in the science of
expertise
the science of expertise is quite
fascinating this fellow named
anders ericsson created it in 1983 it
was not a science before that
he started visiting these
training facilities around the world
that turned out
disproportionately large numbers of
high-level ballerinas chess players
olympic ski champions
all these highly specialized skills
and some people were turning out
substantial experts more than anybody
else so he went and visited them and
hung out with them and studied what they
were doing
and took all the stuff that he learned
from these
coaches and studied it scientifically
and then took it even further
and he died this summer but his last
book called
peak really synthesized it
all really substantially and that's
considered the high water mark
in the war in the world of training
expertise this guy
invented the science changed the whole
thing
and um then the last book is the
is the is the high watermark and that's
required reading in my course it's
course material for the class
so one of the things they talk about
either in the science of learning or
peak
in in the science of expertise is that
they've found that the harder it is
to learn something the better you retain
it
so what i did
so these talk about changing gears
pulling the rug out from under the
students
flipping things on their head making
them work for it
all these ways to make it to make them
more independent and aggressive and
proactive as learners
means that it sticks much better in them
because you want permanent substantial
know-how
not mere knowledge if you know
stuff about things that doesn't mean you
can actually
do it at a professional level just
because you have
knowledge about it so
uh as like i finished one course
and i was getting ready to one lesson
and i was changing to another whole
topic and
i was like okay so how can i utilize
what i've learned
best now that i'm starting
a whole new area and one of the things
they found that's quite fascinating is
that if you
give if you make people
tackle a problem before they've been
trained in it
that it makes them better students
better thinkers for instance in math
a teacher would give you a problem that
you're not equipped to solve yet
and that you haven't been trained in yet
and the teacher would say look
i'm not trying to get you to solve it i
just want you to wrestle with it
take a whack at it see what you can do
and
then when the teacher explains the tool
later on
and the teacher is showing one complex
part of that equation
and the teacher says it so here's the
trick for how you do this particular
thing
instead of the students being there like
i hate this stuff they're like oh
that's how you do that wow look at that
they're invested in it they've already
done part of the work and they're like
they're you know they're aggressive
independent thinkers
really trying to learn it rather than
bored kids
wishing they were out playing frisbee or
whatever so it's a it's a way to
it's a specific methodology of teaching
that has proven to work and so i brought
that in as much as i could
into training in the craft or the
dramatist
so that i will give my students a
complex idea that i haven't
trained them in yet and ask them to just
think it through
and it's an exercise called think it
through just think about it for
15 minutes and then write for five
minutes and i'm not
expecting you to get it right some of
you know more than others and you will
some of you
don't know anything but take a whack at
it like what's the difference between a
storyteller and a dramatist
there's real distinctions and someone
with more experience would understand
that someone who doesn't
might have trouble with it but they can
wrestle with it and they can think about
it and
whatever thinking they do adds up and it
informs their learning process and
it turns them into
more sophisticated students
uh for instance one of the things in my
class
is that not only
do i not answer i only really teach one
thing the craft of the dramatist
and i don't answer any questions about
anything else because i need i want the
focus and i don't want
questions that are unrelated and
i don't answer stupid questions where
i'll say
no you go think about that some more
you're just
tossing out a dumb question like you see
that a lot on
like facebook writer groups where people
post these
really dumb questions like should my
protagonist's girlfriend have red hair
it's like first of all who cares but why
are you asking us
that's my main reaction is you can't
figure that out on your own it's like
you know you're a writer get some grit
dig in and figure it out and so
that all factors into the cognitive
apprenticeship because i'm teaching them
how to think
and how to process and how to
tackle things at a professional level
and so that by the time they've gone
through the program
they will
be much more aggressive independent
thinkers
and they also learn to evaluate their
own ideas
you have to be able to generate ideas
and you also have to be able to evaluate
them
because you can make up stuff all day
long but if half of it's no good and you
can't tell the difference
it doesn't do anybody any good you're
not going to sell it you know it's
it's not working so one of the things i
do
is that in the forum with the groups of
students
i might give them an assignment if we're
all working on the same script
i'd say okay we got to figure out a way
that she can sneak the gun into this
room before the meeting
and it has to be good it can't be some
stupid idea so let's
your assignment is to come up with 10
different ways she could sneak the gun
into the room
and then when they before they post it
post their answer on the forum that
everybody can see i say
then look at your ideas and bubble sort
them let the best ones bubble to the top
so your top three are good and then
post them and then everybody look at
everybody else's
and take take the best of all those and
bubble sort those into the best
so that what you bring me is the top 30
out of what maybe hundreds or more ideas
and then i'm making them do the work
so that they're gaining skill at
creating
evaluating collaborating which is also
very important in the
entertainment industry and
they can work as a team to present me
with
ideas that are everywhere from
very good to incredibly good to off the
charts good
and some of them might be so good that
we're like wow that's a whole screenplay
on itself let's park that over here
and make that into something so
that it's a it's a way of
just making them into
professional storytellers on top of
seasoned versatile dramatists because
you gotta have both
uh great storytelling without craft as a
dramatist
it still won't be stage worthy it won't
work as a performance piece
and that actors can act and will grip an
audience
and mere structure isn't worth very much
either
well-structured crap is still crap it
just runs like a swiss watch
so you really got to have both and
so the cognitive apprenticeship
is apprenticeship in
the craft of the dramatist how to make a
story work dramatically
and the craft of storytelling
and the whole thought process
thought processes that go into all of
that
is crucial because how you think is how
you mold your story
and how you dramatize it and just your
general attack as a storyteller so
you're coming up with
things that are fresh and things that
aren't
you know just cliche and easy to come up
with
you know so it's about challenging them
and making them work for it
and really
bringing up their level of expertise and
their cognitive facilities
and then there's one more layer in
cognitive apprenticeship which is that
you not only need the actual hard skill
but you also need the cognitive facility
the subtle
thinking habits and often
hidden thinking habits that the expert
has
some of which the expert doesn't even
know they're doing so by spending time
with them you gradually see how they
tackle a problem even if they're not
aware of all of it because they may have
forgotten a bunch of it 20 years ago
or sort of invented it subconsciously or
just have good habits because of all
their training
and so in addition to the hard skill and
the cognitive
facility there's also what's called
metacognition
which is the ability to evaluate your
own cognitive process
to get above your own professional
thinking process and go you know
i think i was going about this all wrong
like what i was doing was correct
but i think i'm like in the wrong
ballpark so the ability to
look at your thinking and go god you
know i think i was completely wrong
about that whole part of it
and then you like you may invent a whole
new way to do it or just change
gears or you know maybe you had a
team of 10 people working on a project
for you
and you realize that they didn't need
one person doing it for two days could
do what they were trying to do
10 people in two weeks but the other
part of the problem
you should have had 30 people on for the
last three months because
you noticed how much more significant
this one piece of the puzzle was
when you stepped back and looked at your
own cognitive process
so it's the it's the ability to
um master your own mastery in a certain
way
and that's a that's a key component of
cognitive apprenticeship as well but
it's a full
it's a full bunch of skill sets and it
really lends itself well
to training people on the craft of
script writing
never let anyone tell you that a story's
already been told
yeah that's a fun one um
it goes back to
being a bull in a china shop as a writer
that
your attack as a storyteller is so key
to succeeding as a writer
um
[Music]
lazy writing limp writing
it's it's often so forgettable
and the key word in the entertainment
industry is outrageousness people
go to the movies or watch a tv show or
go to the theater
to see something extraordinary
something different something energizing
something
fun or exciting or meaningful or
cathartic so
[Music]
it has to do with
a rebellious streak
where
you know many people have heard the
saying
there's nothing new under the sun every
story's been told
there's only seven basic stories or
three basic stories or whatever
and part of me completely understands
that
and part of me that just pisses me off
it's like you know
you can't tell me that i can't come up
with something
that's that you've never seen that will
it just
it's like waving a red flag in front of
a bull it
it just makes me mad and it it brings
out
the attack in me and the
desire to shatter people's expectations
and blow people's minds and
take them where they've never been and
just violate their expectations violate
my own storytelling rut
you know it's you know think of a movie
like
being john malkovich you know it's like
so
off the beaten track
and i'm sure there was somebody
telling the writer oh you shouldn't do
that that's not how stories go it's like
it's just weak and it's
it's such a lack of adventure
and a lack of courage and and
just you know one of my favorite terms
is attack as a storyteller
how much attack do you bring to the
table what
what are the ways that you can dazzle an
audience take them on a ride that
they've never been on
and if you accept the idea that you
can't possibly come up with something
that
nobody's ever seen then
it kind of takes the wind out of your
sails in a certain way it says you're
you're not all that creative you can't
come up with something it's like i
i refuse to play that way
i go the other end of the spectrum i
always want to
know what are the extremes in any story
idea
just to see what they are
you often you know you'll find yourself
if you're
trying to solve a story problem where
you got to figure out a specific thing
in a story
where there's kind of a normal set of
possibilities
and then there's unusual possibilities
and then there's extreme possibilities
and like for instance the coen brothers
say that if somebody can figure out
our next move if they had a week to
figure it out and they can figure it out
in a week
we're not going to use it they go way
above and beyond
shaking up your expectations
violating your expectations if
you're trying to solve a story problem
and you have
a selection of possibilities for ways
you could get out of that situation or
whatever
one of the things i've found is really
fun
is is to not only look at the extremes
because it gets you out of the stock
choices in the ordinary
but what i also want to know just out of
pure curiosity
is what's the single craziest
possibility
in the whole universe for that
particular choice what it's like
wildly crazy and usually it won't work
at all
but sometimes you'd be like well that's
interesting if i backed it down a few
notches it could start to
fit into my arena and it's really fresh
and different
and takes the story in a different
direction and
shakes up the character and
every once in a while that single
craziest idea
works brilliantly in a completely
unexpected way
i've had that happen to me where i said
well what's the single craziest idea and
it would be like
well it would be that and be like whoa i
never would have thought of that and i'm
using that it's great so it's
that's part of attack as a storyteller
just going for it and
not just stretching the envelope
envelope but
you know obliterating it and just having
fun you know it's
writing's fun but you're using analogies
similar to war and or combat in some way
is is going
facing the the page every day like
combat
it's a good question because
it depends in many ways on who you are
because if you are
someone with the martial arts skills of
bruce lee say
then you get into the ring
with pretty much any fighter you can
figure something out
so it's so it's not like god i don't
know what i'm gonna do i'm staring at
the blank page it's like
no i can i can make this work you know
this guy weighs 600 pounds so i got to
figure something out
but you know bruce lee is going to bring
a lot of stuff to the table
so the more skill you have as a
storyteller
and as a scriptwriter as a dramatist
the less intimidated you are
by a normal array of writing challenges
now you really
want to get in over your head if it's
all too
easy then you're not doing your job
right
so like if i'm starting in on a script
and it starts to get complex and deep
part of my brain goes uh-oh we're
getting in over our my head here
and the other part of my brain goes yeah
that's that's good that's where you want
to be
and they say that writers are like show
horses
they're not happy unless they're trying
to jump over something that could kill
them
and i was thinking about that last night
and i found an actually much better
analogy
is that writers are like extreme
rock climbers or something they're not
happy climbing something
unless it could well kill them if it's
too less of a challenge they're like
they're bored that's they get their
adrenaline
from the fact that nobody's ever climbed
this cliff
and they're doing with no ropes and
they're hanging by you know like two
fingers on a
piece of rock that big and they're like
this is fun
this is life and they don't want to do
anything else
they even found that the like the combat
nurses and medics who came back from
vietnam
couldn't go back to a normal job it was
too i can't sit in a corner and file
papers
so they ended up as like emergency room
physicians and
you know frontline cops so like they had
to be in
in the deep stuff to because it was it
didn't cut it anymore for them
so the more craft
you bring to the table the less
intimidated you are by the material
but you also want to be
in over your head they said that bob
marley who grew up
on the water when they got bored he and
his brother would swim out to sea as far
as they could until they were completely
exhausted
and then they'd try to make it back to
shore that was their idea of like a fun
afternoon so it's kind of like that it's
like
the material should challenge you but
you should also
be throwing hand grenades into your own
story ideas to make your job harder
to challenge yourself so that like a
rock climber is like i'm not going to
take that safe route i'm going to do
this
dangerous route over here that nobody's
ever done before
and it may well kill me but i can't live
without that level of challenge
so i'm not sure if that answered your
question exactly
i think it does i think that basically
you're saying you need to be
stimulated but not bored and it can't be
too easy
and so it's kind of like playing chess a
hobbyist playing chess
with an expert versus a hobbyist playing
chess with another hobbyist
right and that
the the more substantial your craft as a
writer
the less it seems like how can i
possibly do this
you know it's a job it's a story and
of course it's challenging and it's hard
but like bruce lee
facing whatever opponent he's like
i may get my ass kicked but i know what
i'm doing and i can take this on
you know i'm not it's not like what am i
going to do what am i going to do it's
like no i know exactly what i'm going to
do
i just have to figure out how to do it
for this particular thing
can you define a dramatist versus a
storyteller
sure a storyteller is just
making up a story and
any kind of story whether you're making
up a little five-minute
story for your kid to go to sleep with
or you're
coming up with uh lord of the rings or
game of thrones yeah like
[Music]
high-end complex storytelling
that's huge and to succeed as a
scriptwriter you need storytelling
skills as big as you can get them
the craft of the dramatist is connected
to storytelling
but distinct from it also because
the craft of the dramatist is how you
dramatize a story
to adapt it for theatrical presentation
so it has you have to make your story so
that actors can perform it
on film on tv on stage and
that it grips the audience so the
audience is on the edge of their seat
wondering what comes next
you're making the material compelling
and conformable
performable so
the craft of the dramatist is
ancient
the first person who really chimed in on
it
that we know of was aristotle
he was not a playwright but each year
athens had a religious theater festival
in which a topic was assigned
to the playwrights of athens so
aristotle would over a couple day period
see
25 different versions of euripides not
you that was a playwright of um
well what's i'm blanking on the name of
the
play um oedipus so
uh he was able to compare and contrast
all these different playwrights takes on
the edible myth
and he found that some of them put the
audience to sleep and some of them
really gripped the audience
and he's like well what is it about
those dramas that grip an audience is
there anything common
among them and he found that they tended
to have a good strong dilemma
building to a crisis forcing decision
action in the face of crisis
with with a resolution of the dilemma by
the protagonist
and uh a denum the upshot the epilogue
these were things that aristotle noticed
tended to be common to those dramas that
gripped an audience and then
throughout the years there were french
classicists who
did amazing work and um
shakespeare and and you know just
playwrights in general
and the science has continued to evolve
um there was a a new set of tools were
created
by this um script this broadway script
dr william thompson price
uh that he put out in his book 1908 and
he was teaching to his students
and he created these tools
because he found
that
most of the scripts that were submitted
for broadway productions that he was
working with the broadway producers on
missed the mark in some way a high
degree of them and that's still true
today that
90 to 95 of all scripts submitted
are do not work at all
they're horrible rejected unreadable
and the studio readers say don't kid
yourself it's 98
so what price did was he said these
people
are not landing in the ballpark very
often and
they're not stupid and they're good
storytellers they don't have enough
craft as a dramatist
and price was trained as a lawyer that
was his first
profession and
being trained in the logic of
argumentation
the ability to state a complete court
case
as a and b therefore c
and that is a rigorous process and if
you
present the logic of a court case
in the proper way then it's irrefutable
you prove your case by a and b therefore
c and your client wins
so he said there ought to be a way to
state the complete action of a script
with that level of simplicity and
clarity
and he by by
adapting the proposition of logic
to drama he created this tool because a
proposition is a
and b therefore c you're proposing that
this is true and this is true therefore
this is true
and he
worked on it for a long time
he never ceased to be dissatisfied with
it but he
created it and advanced it and was able
to help their students
his students plays work 24 of his 28
students
had hits on broadway um
[Music]
but he was constantly trying to
synthesize it better
but it definitely worked and
there was another playwriting teacher
who i found out later was
who taught price's technique of the
proposition
after price died in 1920 uh
prices student wrote a book in 1928
which is what those two books i read for
three years
and then this other playwriting teacher
wrote a book in 1950 but he'd been
teaching crisis proposition
and he advanced it even further
and what this teacher said was
um
i'm trying to remember the exact wording
can i read it to you from my book it's
i have it right here if that's helpful
oh you do okay
i know it by memory but i'm not dredging
up all of it
this is my book writing a great movie uh
key tools for successful screenwriting
so let me read you actually a quote by
price about the proposition he's writing
in
1912. one main proposition is the
essence of unity
it is unity and unity can be procured in
no other way
it is impossible that two main ideas
exist in the same play
the house will be divided against itself
two bodies cannot occupy the same space
at the same time
the play itself that which is developed
from the one idea
is about many things but the discerning
eye of the author should penetrate to
the heart of things
true dramatic instinct which is largely
the product of training
usually does this with unerring
promptness for that one idea is
naturally the largest idea
a proposition involves the whole play it
must have a certain magnitude and the
play must be commensurate with it
it suggests action for the last clause
reply requires that a problem be worked
out
doubt is expressed the facts are given
opposition is encountered
so that's price talking about it and
then here is bernard grobanier
in his book playwriting
he says eventually price was able to
formulate his law of plot the
proposition
which we are quite willing to agree is
the one significant contribution to the
science of playwriting since aristotle's
poetics
this was the judgment of many of his
students among whom were the most
successful american dramatists of their
generation
it is a large remark but as we say we do
not dispute it
even though price's very name seems
unknown to the public or to the scholars
these days
if we ourselves were asked to whom we
were indebted for the basis of our ideas
about playwriting
we should have to answer aristotle and
price price
really brought something entirely
new to the craft of the dramatist to the
craft of
making a story work dramatically for a
presentation
to an audience in such a way that it
grips the audience
and it's it's a
it's a complete craft in its own
and it's just
entirely distinct from storytelling from
one point of view
and yet completely married to it
because your dramatizing story
it's one of the things that i an analogy
that i recently
stumbled onto because what i'm teaching
is
seven powerful tools and
we spend two years learning them in this
training program so we'll spend months
on each one
and you have to acquire expert facility
with each tool
and then you gradually synthesize them
together into one unified
expertise and i compare it to learning
how to
juggle while you're riding on a unicycle
on a tightrope
you have to learn each of those skills
separately and then
synthesize them together into a fluid
capability
so it's just a set of skills
that you get better and better at
and you have to keep improving your
storytelling
because if your story ideas are weak it
doesn't matter how much craft you have
as a dramatist if your stories lack
magnitude then
it's not going to help much
and that was a point echoed by uh
ted elliott or terry rozio they wrote
pirates of the caribbean and a whole
bunch of other stuff
they said one of the most central
problems we
see in scriptwriters trying to succeed
is that their
core idea is poor
and that's so true
people put all this energy into
trying to turn a weak idea into a
stage-worthy script
and it's it's so
central to it uh i had dinner with a
showrunner of a top um
network uh tv series
and she was saying that
she sees so much bad writing that
will not work for their show and she
can't show it to their
to the star because he won't do it
and she said that there's that the
writing itself
is often so poor that you have to like
decipher it to get out what they're
trying to say
and when you finally get down to the
kernel of the idea
it sucks too it's like there's no there
there there's all this stuff built
around something that doesn't work in
the first place
so storytelling is hugely important
and the craft of the dramatist is hugely
important
you can't succeed as a scriptwriter
without both of them
dialed to 11.
how do most non-professional
screenwriters create plot
often it's the same as professional
screenwriters
but professional screenwriters
can evaluate what they're creating
whereas non-professionals don't have the
ability to
[Music]
eyeball their material at a professional
critique level
so that they'll get excited about an
idea they have
it can either be too derivative where
it's
been used in way
too many movies or tv shows or stage
plays
so that most
people wouldn't be interested in it
unless the execution of it is
extraordinary
which kind of by definition a
non-professional scriptwriter
is generally not capable of doing now
some people are just
out of the box geniuses and that's
different but
not only is that extremely rare but
uh anders erickson in his book peak
said that they
looked everywhere for prodigies who
were out of the box and just
could do it
with no training as good as the best
people they said those people
do not exist and they've scoured the
earth for them
you hear about them but it's not true so
that
for instance say someone has an innate
ability at chess
and maybe they were a prodigy as added
as a kid
but didn't
push their capabilities
and they may still still perceive
themselves
as a prodigy but if you put them up
against a genuine chess master
they've never found anybody who
without the proper training could go all
the way
uh and i'd never heard that before i
thought there was such a thing as
prodigy anders eriksen calls it the
prodigy
myth and they pretty much categorically
disproved it
you know and i think that writers who
come out of left field and who never had
any formal training
and who write stuff that works in
really unusual ways or they're just
brilliant at it
they probably worked their butts off
it's not like they woke up one morning
and said i think i'll be a screenwriter
today
and spit out a masterpiece they may be
coming at it completely from left field
but they put the work into it so there's
the distinction
in that so there's no savant there's no
screenwriting savant where
they're able to to emulate you know how
some these savants can
can play a masterpiece without having
known music in terms of reading notes
and things like that i
i think there probably are but i think
they
also worked their butt off to
polish their craft but you never know
anything's quite possible
the real problem is that most
scripts suck seriously
and so those are hard numbers
that realistically 98 and some people
say it's 99.9
of all scripts submitted are
unreadable uh
for a variety of reasons but if you
don't have it all
working together on the page then the
script doesn't work
and so
how non-professional writers
come up with ideas
is really all across the board
from you know watching some movie
and wanting to basically just copy it
to having
like a fever dream that they wake up
from in a cold sweat and like
my god i gotta write that and maybe it's
brilliant
and and often they are uh
but almost always
they have to have the craft to execute
it properly
you know maybe it's a story their
grandfather told them about what
happened to them in world war ii or
whatever and
it electrifies them and they want to
turn it into a story
it might be just rolling ideas around in
their head and
[Music]
two odd ideas clank together at one
point you'll be like
that's a weird story you know sometimes
it's just colliding two different
stories together
uh the story alfred bester tells
um he wrote an amazing book of short
stories called the golden man
and one of them is called fondly
fahrenheit
and it's about a robot a really high-end
robot in the future that
is the apex of robot invention and it
can literally
carve marble like michelangelo like
anything and he hires it out to do jobs
and it makes him a good living but it
gets overheated
and something goes wrong and the robot
kills the person it was with
so then he goes on the run with it and
puts it out for lesser jobs because
they're looking for the robot that can
carve like michelangelo
so now he has a teaching latin you know
on another planet
and it overheats and kills some so he
keeps going on the run and keeps
downgrading
what he's hiring the robot for and
bester talked about the creation of that
idea and the original idea was basically
that was that
high-end robot malfunctions and he said
it just wasn't enough it was it was not
a complex idea it was too simple
and he shelved it and then
a number of years later he came across
the description of a psychological
malady in which one person thinks
they're another person where
i genuinely think i'm you
and it's like a it's like a mental
illness
and i act like i'm you and i interact
with you like i'm you
and he said that's really interesting
never heard of that before
and as he was like rolling it around in
his hands he reached up for the other
idea and he did what he called
collide them together to where this
robot that was malfunctioning
part of the malfunction is that the
robot thinks it's the master
and he said now that had some juice as a
story
and he made it into a fascinating short
story called fondly fahrenheit
and it's amazing you know and it's just
that kind of thing and that's
one of the things that we do in
the two-year training program that i'm
doing
is that each student has
the the core of the course the 18-month
center of the course
we're constantly working on about
six to eight scripts at the same time
when we range from one to the next
so we might be working on an action
thriller then the next day we're on a
wacko comedy and the next day it's a
horror story and the next day is
like an adventure story so we're
changing gears constantly they're
learning different genres
and using the same tools and techniques
across a full spectrum of ideas
but they also have writing assignments
exercises to gain
facility with the individual skills
learning games and other things and one
of the things they have to do
is to spit out a new story idea every
day
and i emphasize like just
spit it out don't get precious with it
don't beat yourself up
and if
they love the idea they keep it in their
private folder if it's just
some dumb idea they just spit up with
they're not attached to it they put it
into the group
story bin so that anybody can work with
it we play with it we'll take one and go
let's create a dilemma for that
and if it begins to have legs then
that'll become one of the six to eight
scripts that we build
and in the process of them generating a
story idea every day
you know i'm saying to them don't worry
if it's dumb don't
try to come up with genius stuff just
keep spitting them out
because in the course of this two years
you'll develop hundreds of ideas
and you'll get in the habit of spitting
them out and i said you know you may
find
that you end up colliding your
stupid bank robbery movie with your
crazy time travel story and like you
collide those two together and all of a
sudden you got a fun comedy
out of two lame looking ideas
so that's part of what i try to bring
to helping my students
acquire better attack as storytellers
and
just better facility creating stories
and being able to
recognize a lousy idea from a good one
um oh and by the way uh
the term attack as a storyteller uh came
from
the writer alfred bester
he um he was a big influence on me as a
writer he wrote
two phenomenal novels science fiction
novels in 1954 and 56
one was the stars my destination the
other one is the demolished man
and he's in many ways considered one of
the absolute godfathers of science
fiction
he was like the primary influence on all
these people like heinlein
and um uh
arthur c clarke all these people like
worshiped him and
took off you know built upon the level
of energy that he brought
he was a he originally
wrote radio plays for the shadow
that was a you know radio play the
shadow knows and comic book stories and
he said that kind of comic book writing
taught him a lot about attack as a
storyteller entertainment value
the outrageousness of great storytelling
and just he said writing for a radio
play you got to get
right honored he said start at white
heat and build from there
so his his his attack
as a storyteller has influenced me a lot
and i
try to um
inspire my students to that level of
kind of ferocity like you know
it's like be a wild animal to become a
writer to be
domesticated creature to be told what to
do and
sit in a corner and salute you know it's
like
don't let anybody tell you how to do
this stuff
you know it's just it's just the
the whole society teaches people to
conform and sit down and shut up and
not it it doesn't say don't be original
but it
defuses in the in the in the sense of
diffuse like make it weaker diff usc but
also
defuse like to disarm a bomb
to take away the fangs and claws
of people they people are domesticated
in society
and we need wild animals you know we
need people that are out there
pushing the borders and seeing things in
an
entirely new way and refusing to accept
the way things are
and that's so much the job of
storytellers is to
lead the way and inspire and show people
new ways to do things
um but hang on i'm so sorry to interrupt
you but
i like what you're saying but let me
just play the devil's advocate for a
second
if you don't know the rules you can't
break them kind of thing
so right when when you say to to
push back and don't let someone tell you
what to do what if someone's
this free sort of loose cannon but
they're going about story in the wrong
way
and then yeah okay there's lots of
different
there's really an infinite number of
approaches to
any kind of story or anything
you know like even just the way quentin
tarantino with pulp fiction
kind of flipped
storytelling in a certain way that we
hadn't seen
done in movies much before and did it
really well
but he still had really sophisticated
structural technique because he
had three different stories
written into a coherent hole so it
wasn't a mess
it was a gem so there's so many
different ways to tackle it
and what i'm talking about is
attack as a storyteller there's a
difference between
wildly explosive creativity as a
storyteller
and substantial craft as a dramatist
so there are
not so much rules for a dramatist
but a process of thinking habits of mind
like how do you make something work
for for traumatic presentation
real actors acting it out in front of an
audience and it grabs the audience it's
all about the audience
if a movie playing to an empty theater
has no power it's just shadows on the
wall
the power of the film resides in the
response of the audience
so
you want like wildly aggressive
storytelling and
rigorous technique as a dramatist it's
like
it's it's it's an interesting
intersection
of something that's organic and messy
and something that's a hard science like
medicine is a good example
because medicine taking on like
weird forms of cancer or something that
keep evolving and it's not
like they can control it they're just
bringing a rigorous science
to grapple with this organic thing
and uh your story idea might be
unlike anything anybody's ever seen
and yet you still have to make it work
as a performance medium
so that your craft as a dramatist can
help you
wrestle that story into
a shape that makes it performable and
gripping
without sterilizing it you're not trying
to
defang its energy you're just trying to
make it so that it actually works so
that actors can really act it
and it really grabs an audience so it's
it's kind of like inherently
contradictory or it may sound that way
at first
but really it's just like make your
stories as
explosively creative as you possibly can
and it's kind of like
with the old samsonite luggage where you
put a whole bunch of stuff in and then
you
kneel on it and just click the latches
and then it's in there
if you can get that story into shape so
that it's
performable and grabs the audience then
it works
you know even if it's something as out
there as being john malkovich
where you're like watching the movie
going whoa look at that
and you know it's brilliant and it's fun
and it's different
and it works it grabs an audience it's
actible
and yet it's coming not even from left
field but like
way out there and it's we need that kind
of
fresh energy and refusal to knuckle
under to normal story patterns and
even the crafter the dramatist the more
craft you have
see it comes down to principle and
method
there are certain principles that
underlie
what tend to make the tools work and
there are certain
methods that embody those principles so
like if the if you have certain
principles
that are active there are certain
methods that are created
that turn that principle into an
implement
and so that the particular tool you're
using
may not work exactly for the story
you're trying to tell
but it but you can adapt the story
because you're still
serving the same principle there just
may be a different mechanism
that can embody that principle
so that you the more craft you have as a
dramatist the more
you can adapt because you're still
you're still achieving what you want to
achieve you just find a different way to
do it
can you give me an example of a
domesticated
writer and i'm not talking about
physically and at home
staying home during covid just just
someone that
is in a mindset of sort of the masses
and versus this
wild unhinged feral writer well
generally those are
the writers of the scripts that don't
work of which there are
millions of them over you know decades
so that even if you look for instance
at a movie that seems very calm on the
surface like
ordinary people it won best picture and
a bunch of other oscars i think in 80 or
something around there it's almost just
a parlor drama
like people sitting around a living room
arguing
but there's so much intensity and so
much ferocity and so much attack it
really goes right for the jugular vein
it's not making weak choices
it's making very strong choices and
really
making us take a good hard look at the
ugly or dysfunctional parts of ourselves
so that it has a tremendous attack a lot
of magnitude a lot of
depth so
and that's like what i'm talking about
when i say domesticated i just mean like
making small safe choices
where you know you're reading the script
and you like that you like
the pitch and then you read the script
and it's like
the pitch sounded so promising and they
just sat back and
you know phoned it in look at like at
this juncture they could have made
so many better choices but they made a
weak one and then it just
keeps it's like
you know just a lack of attack
you had talked about attention versus
intention
so that has to do with
what um in what anders ericsson in his
book peak and in his whole career
talks about as deliberate practice
and that is that say that you're
a you're in training to be an olympic
ski racer
and it's a series of
individual skills that each of which has
to be
better than anybody in the world if
you're going to win like
every move you make so that
your coach is showing you video of
like as a skier i know that you to ski
right you're doing six things at the
same time
you have to do all at once and then
you're really good
but you have to learn each one in
isolation and then combine them so your
coach
would be saying you're leaning a little
too
forward there and you're not popping on
your when you when you change
you know and they'll and they'll isolate
certain things that they need to improve
upon
like you keep you keep not straightening
your knee so they might give them
exercise and have them do it a lot
for instance like one of my friends who
was a
played minor league hockey the junior b
they call it his coach would show them
how to do it and then say
go do that 50 000 times and then come
back it's that type of thing a
deliberate practice where your ski coach
would say
you keep not extending your elbow all
the way you gotta
overcome that so every day you'll do
that
maybe a thousand times before you do
anything else and instead of going
i hate this you you you do it with full
attention and full intention
so that you're really paying attention
to it and
you're intending to like i'm gonna
master this
and yeah it's boring and everything else
but you're you stay focused
and that makes your brain build the
neural network stronger and better
whereas if you're not focused and don't
have strong intention
then you don't really get the the
cumulative benefit
in the brain structure that seats it as
a
deeply habitual so you once you've done
that
the whole season when you get into the
race then
every time you take a turn you never
miss that elbow lock
so that it becomes built in and that's
what erickson called
deliberate practice and what they said
was that
they found that you don't want to give
the people your training drills but give
them short addictive games
they're literally doing the exact same
thing but you make an addictive game out
of it so that they can stay focused on
it better
what do you think of writers who don't
need to outline to write a great story
well there's so many different
approaches
uh i mean the bottom line is either the
story they're writing works or it
doesn't
if it doesn't work and they don't
outline then it may be something that
they want to add to their repertoire
if it does work then whatever they've
created as their process
it works if the story if people love the
story then whatever they do works
it's just one approach to
the process of creating developing and
constructing a story
for me it's a deep habit to do that
because
one of the central problems for
scriptwriters
is that dramatic writing is an extremely
stripped down literary
form it demands complete economy
mostly because it's a performance medium
and the only thing that actually
it's like an iceberg where there's a
bunch of
parts of the story that are
you know part of the mechanics of the
story but the part that the audience
actually
sees on stage or on screen is just
a sequence of events that happens like
the guy walks into the room to
get his valuable thing from out of
hiding
and there's somebody watching from the
window or behind the curtain with a
knife
and it's just a sequence of events where
the person gets the thing out of hiding
then the other person comes out and
tries to take it from them
so it's a highly specific set of
incidents
and there isn't room
for anything else in that particular
scene
and this is called separating the
necessary from the unnecessary
so that the performance
generally it won't it won't make it to
performance if it's
bogged down with the unnecessary because
the script doesn't read well
but people will often put
will allow the unnecessary to creep into
the script from all different directions
and the outlining process
the way i use it and the way i train in
it is that
you have to get the big building blocks
of your story
working first because if the
if the major girders and beams if the
big bones of your story
don't work dramatically
then nothing else you add to it is gonna
matter
the details don't matter it's like
some writers will have a beautifully
written scene in a script that doesn't
work
it doesn't amount to anything it's like
having an ornately finished room and a
house that's falling over
you've got gold leaf and oak and marble
and everything else
but the house is literally tipping over
so
if you got to get the big structure
right and that's
the most basic component
of an outline once you get that working
then you layer in a little more detail
so if you have a sequence of events that
constitutes the spine of your story and
those are just
the big building blocks of your story
with no detail
and you link those up and you take a
look at it and go
oh that's better than i thought it would
be or i could see how i thought i had a
problem in act two and i can see that
clearly now that i've got the major
building blocks and then you improve on
that
and then look at it again and go yeah
now that works then
you can break that up into acts and
develop a little more detail for act one
so you gradually layer in a little more
detail as it becomes necessary
but layering on only that which is
necessary
then you do act two and act three then
you take act one and break it down into
sequences there's two to five sequences
in an act
and two to five scenes in a sequence so
you break
the opening act down into say three or
four sequences
you take the first sequence and you've
already got
a chain of events that you've already
figured out from when you figured out
the act
and then you expand upon that a little
more it becomes necessary to think it
through in a little more detail
so you flesh out your outline a little
bit more
and then you do it for the next sequence
and you flesh that out and it's
flesh out not flush out like putting
flesh on bones
and you do that for all the sequences
you develop
a little more detail so now
you've got an outline that has
a reasonable amount of detail to it and
this sequence serves
where is it is tight and dramatic in
and of itself when the audience watched
that sequence there on the edge of their
seat
it's compelling that sequence
serves its function of
what the act is intended to do the act
this unit serves this unit this is part
of this and contributes toward what the
act is trying to do
the act serves the whole because it does
it's part of the mechanism
that helps make the whole story work so
it's a unit inside of a unit inside of a
unit so then you take
the opening sequence and you divide it
down into scenes
and you so
if like this if this is your opening
sequence
and there's a chain of events that
constitute that sequence
you're going to say okay this part of it
is the opening scene
so there's still that chain of events
that you'd already figured out that are
constitute that scene
now you're going to take those events
and think it through in a little more
detail
you expand upon it a little more and now
you've got final detail
so you have a highly detailed outline
and then you actually write that scene
then you think through the next scene
and expand upon the detail
but you're still rigorously excluding
the unnecessary and only layering in
that which is necessary
to the sequence of events it's all about
the forward progression
of events and that has to do that's
particular
to dramatic writing in a novel you
really have a lot more leeway and flow
and but but in something that's being
staged you have to
present a clear forward progression
and you and you want that progression to
move well and not
veer off into unrelated territory
or you don't want to have a dead spot
that's flat dramatically so you lose the
audience
the the basically continuous coherent
compelling dramatic action
is the name of the game and dramatic
action is not car chases and shootouts
it's not mere action it's a state of
action that you put the audience in
it's all about getting the audience on
the edge of their seat and keeping them
there
they're in a state of action the
audience so continuous
coherent compelling dramatic action the
word compelling is actually redundant
because dramatic action is by definition
compelling but it just helps people
understand it better
so if it's you always want to have
dramatic action you don't want to ever
revert to mere story you don't want to
have parts of your script go flat
dramatically where it's mere information
you want it to always be actible and
compelling
so this
the scene still is
a causes b which causes c which causes d
and so on it moves
it has a good progression of forward
action with nothing
it's it's only that which is going to be
on stage or on screen with nothing else
it's
you continuously strip away the
unnecessary and the unnecessary kill
scripts
the unnecessary you have overwritten
dialogue overwritten descriptions
overwritten scenes scenes that shouldn't
be there
sequences that shouldn't be there
bloated sequences sometimes you have
a whole act that's unnecessary and
what price said was for that matter your
entire script may be unnecessary
which is true way more often than it
should be
those 98 of scripts that don't work are
unnecessary they do not work they
they're landfill they they they can't do
anything with them
so if you
if you are rigorously excluding the
unnecessary
from the big bones of the story to each
act
to each sequence and each scene then you
building the script section by section
and including only that which is
necessary to the forward action of the
story
and the the unnecessary
is rigorously excluded at all times
then your working draft consists of only
that which is necessary
every scene is tight and dramatic
the first three scenes each of which is
tight and dramatic make up
the opening sequence which is in and of
itself tight and dramatic
those four sequences each of which are
titan dramatic makeup the opening act
which in and of itself is titan dramatic
and
each of the acts which are titan
dramatic make up the overall story which
is in and of itself tight and dramatic
so
the working draft that you end up with
is going to
be very much in the ballpark it's going
to be lean and mean
now that doesn't mean it doesn't need
work it generally needs a lot of work
but it's not a bloated mess
it's a tight thing that's highly
functional and
you can it's basically
the whole premise behind what i teach is
that
and this came straight from price that
you can that if you properly engineer
your script
before you write it then it will
uh save most of the you'll you can use
the same amount of energy to properly
engineer your script before you write it
as you would put into 25 rewrites
so it's better to
structure it properly and then write it
and then build from there
and storytelling
is not always so hard to do but dramatic
dramatizing a story
is very tricky what if a writer says
though these are necessary parts to my
story
but outside eyes say no this is
unnecessary unnecessary takes me out of
it
what is missing from this writer that
they think that their
necessary scenes or dialogue is is
actually unnecessary
well well first of all
either they're right or they're not um
either the script works and people want
to make it or it doesn't
if a professional evaluates the script
and says i'm not going to make this
then it doesn't work in that instance
now the next professional they meet
might say
this is brilliant i love it so it's you
know it's
it's flexible in many ways but
it's um
it has to do a lot with
just the craft of a dramatist of that
writer because
they may perceive that something is
necessary to the telling of the story
when actually it only bogs it down
or kills it um
and that happens
a lot if they're overly attached
to the story and
you know how much craft they have
but it's really
the the showrunner i was talking to
she said that she sees so many scripts
that will not work for their
for their show and this is a top this is
one of the top
network shows in the world
and she's the showrunner she's a
showrunner on it
she says she said two things
what they write either is producible our
star will
agree to do it and it will work or
it won't and we're not making it because
it's not what we make
um
she said that
she can tell if somebody can write
really within the first sentence
you know a lot of people say the first
five pages the first page she says yes
first five pages all that but she said i
can tell if they can write or not in the
first sentence
and what often happens is if she
says to this writer this script does not
work and the writer says well that's
just your subjective opinion
she's like they say that to me all the
time but
they're not right it either works or it
doesn't it's not my subjective opinion
it's my professional expertise that i
look at their script for this show
and it does not work and it's not
subjective
so there's
there's professional skill sets and then
there's everybody else's opinion about
what they think is professional writing
and really it's either works or it
doesn't
so
people's attachment to things that they
perceive
are necessary
is often mistaken from either
an emotional attachment to the material
or
a mistaken sense of craft or you know
just they think
they think it helps make the script work
when actually it's
a significant weakness in the material
so they don't know what they don't know
and yeah yeah
or they don't
know enough and they stick to their guns
thinking they've got the goods when
like this showrunner would not
even show it to the star of the show
because you know it's like
it has to be this particular thing to go
into our production
slate and it's either that or it's not
it's we write a certain type of show and
it's
and so the writer telling them look
it'll work
it's fresh it's creative it's like
that doesn't matter it's not what we
produce
so it has to do with
what the professional decision makers
are looking for
and what in their experience ruins
the the script
versus the opinion of the writer
and this show runner said it's not like
these are like
people that never wrote anything these
are rep writers
that are supposed to be professional
writers and they're not even in the
ballpark
so it was
a huge discrepancy between what people
think works
and what the high level decision makers
will let get past their gate to get into
production
could it be that they weren't properly
told
the exact nature of what they're looking
for i'm just playing the devils out no
because the show's been on for years and
it's a
it's a known entity it's like how could
you not know what we
produce here um
but you know is there so many reasons
why people's writing
don't work from their poor storyteller
they don't have craft as a dramatist
or it's just not right for the entity
they're pitching it to their stuff might
be
astonishingly brilliant but it's just
not right for this show so there's
it's you can't really it's not black and
white at all there's
so many different angles and approaches
and
you know somebody might show up in town
tomorrow with the script the likes of
which no one's ever seen in it
makes more money than anything ever done
and wins every award and people are like
what the hell was that we didn't we'd
never seen anything like it
we didn't think it would work and it's
brilliant you know you never
anything can go you know but there's
also
rules that
work in certain ways for
what people are looking for so there are
no rules from one point of view and
there are real rules from another point
of view
and all that's real if you invent an
entirely new type of car
it still has to fit on the damn road fit
in a garage
even if it runs on goldfish you know
it's like it's still gotta
fit certain aspects of the
infrastructure that's out there
right so you can know music you can be
roger daltrey
and still follow the right pitch and
and cadence and all that i don't not i
don't know
much about music but you can still be
unhinged and wild
and now you have tommy and now you have
this like
wild sort of creature and this is what
you're talking about with writing
that you want to see someone that's
that's got fangs and and claws and
yeah even like with ordinary people
there's not a car chase or a gunfight
anywhere within 10 000 miles of that
script but it's
so compelling it's absolutely riveting
and it's shocking it's powerful
so it's more about
not blowing more stuff up but going
deeper and not
going down the same rut that everybody
else is going down you know it's just
don't settle for less
be a dynamic storyteller and
you know don't don't make weak
predictable choices that kind of thing
is what i'm talking about
okay you get that at home for free
people go to the movies to see something
fresh and dynamic and world-changing
they
want the people that go to the movies
are hoping that
your movie will change
the way they think for the rest of their
life
people want transformation
they're starving for it they open up
their brain and go do something anything
they want a real experience they want
you to knock their socks off
they don't want to see the same warmed
over murder mystery that they can
see coming 30 miles away and know who
did it
you know 10 minutes into the movie it's
like
i i don't have this two hours to watch
crap i need something powerful
i have a story idea and i'm hoping that
we can see ways to make it
more wild and and really sort of
shake things up from what i have okay
i'm trying to shorten it down but my
character the protagonist is a male in
his 30s we'll call him derek
and he's always been a techie he majored
in computer science he had a commodore
64.
he's always been very heady and flash
forward many years later he gets a very
lucrative job at a fortune 500 company
where he's in he's in charge of the sort
of i.t department and their security
and it's a dream job but he's totally
bored there's there's nothing he knows
exactly what his life is and he's
completely bored he becomes a workaholic
he doesn't really meet
any romantic partners until one day he
goes to a coffee shop
and a very attractive young woman asks
for help
with her computer well it turns out
unbeknownst to him
he's been targeted by a rival company
and they want to use her
to seduce him so that they can get into
the company's mainframe and find out
trade secrets
so uh her name is skyler what a perfect
name for
for that character and at first when he
realizes he's being used he's upset and
then he realizes he doesn't care anymore
and he's willing because his life really
wasn't what he wanted
and he's fallen in love with this woman
and he knows
that he's being manipulated and he
doesn't care
so um he feels that he can change skyler
and give her a better life
and that uh anyway
help me out here how can i make this
story better um
give it more sort of a wow factor really
shock people with it well it's not just
mere shock value it's
the thing that i would focus on first is
um what's his name again derek
derek um would be a
good strong dilemma for derek being
trapped between two equally
unacceptable alternatives
a good example of that would be in the
movie training day
where the ethan hawk character jake is
caught in a good strong dilemma between
his
his ambition to make it on to
the denzel washington characters
under undercover narcotics squad his
ambition he's very ambitious
and his moral compass because he's
willing to do anything
to make that squad because he wants to
make detective and get his own division
you know become a high-ranking
cop and his ambition is his
weakness so he's overly ambitious
and yet he has a strong moral compass
too so
as alonzo drags him deeper and deeper
into the
basically the trap that alonso has set
for him
his his ambitions are being realized
he's moving forward aggressively and
seeing a path
but that also includes corruption and
questionable activities so his moral
compass is rebelling
so he can't let go of his ambition
nothing will make him let go of his
ambition
but he can't let go of his moral compass
either and they're really
equally strong so that's an example of a
good strong dilemma
so i would the first thing i would focus
on
is a potential dilemma for derek
because there's either a dilemma
inherent in the story idea that
you've pitched or there isn't
if it's there then i want to isolate it
and then amplify it to maximize its
strength
if it's not there i would experiment
with creating one
and and i'm not trying to force a
dilemma onto it
because the story's the most important
thing
but a good strong dilemma can amplify
the dramatic power of a story
and so
i look at the possibility of creating
one without
forcing it or bending the story out of
shape
in this one it seems like there is
a dilemma kind of sitting on the surface
in other words
i'm not having to go is there one in
there i can see it right there because
it's unacceptable to go along
with the manipulation
and generally the dilemma kicks in
somewhere and then around the end of act
one you have to like
live with the character for a while get
to know them get to care about the lead
pro the protagonist and for the story to
develop
um to the point where somewhere around
the end of act one the protagonist
finds him or herself caught in a dilemma
of magnitude
magnitude means significance to an
audience
does it hit them where they live does it
grab them is it important
like you could have a dilemma that it's
unacceptable to wash the car
it's equally unacceptable to mow the
lawn that is in fact a dilemma
but it's not going to grab an audience
it doesn't have magnitude
so so
if after a whole act
one he's noticing that he's the subject
of a manipulation
and he's like i'm not going to allow
myself to i'm not going to i'm not going
to fall for this i'm not going down that
road
and yet we're looking for something
that's
equally unacceptable that like
it's unacceptable to let go of this
kind of wild card that has
disrupted his
predictable career trajectory
which reminds me of the story of the
musician sting
from the police he was the headmaster of
a girls school
in england and he said at one point
he had a a flash where he could see the
whole rest of his life in this
really predictable path and he was like
like whoa i am not doing that like let
me out of here
and he's like you know he's like i like
music i'm
i'm gonna chase that hard so there's
something similar
in derek going
i don't like
the trap that she's leading me into
but i do like the trap she's leading me
into
and so there is that's why i'm saying i
could see a dilemma sitting on the
surface there is a dilemma
inherent in the material which
then now that we have isolated
the the two halves of the dilemma
then the next step that i would do would
be to
experiment with amplifying
each of those halves
so
if i'm him and one way i do is i i put
myself
in derek's shoes so if i'm derek
and not only all my training
in terms of security and i.t and
lockdown
and watching the companies back
and keeping predators out
and knowing that they're out there trade
secrets and all that kind of stuff
that i'm naturally
not only a guard dog
but an attack dog
[Music]
so like it's unacceptable
to let anybody outsmart me
in this stuff because i'm protecting my
master and i'll
i'll take a bullet for them you know
it's the attack dog the secret service
all that stuff is kind of like
wired into him and there's a
professional
ferocity that like nobody's getting
around me
i'm the goalie nobody's scoring on me
and i don't care if i dislocate my arm
and i never play again
they're not putting that puck in that
net the more that that
aspect of his personality can be
amplified
the more what we're doing is we're we're
jacking up
that side of the dilemma
by playing what if
with what are the things that it's like
putting a jack under it and jacking it
up a little
and at first it'll go right up and then
it'll be like you can still get one more
click out of it and like what's the most
intense you can make it
and and there's a variety of factors
that would inform that and go into that
um one of the things you see often is a
past failure
um or he's not going to let it happen
again
or and maybe that goes hand in glove
with a character defect on himself
or but it's really just like
like my dog will die to keep you from
hurting my kids
that kind of thing you are not getting
past
that watchdog
so amplifying that
and then and and you can see how that
it's not that hard
to beef that up to make him a ferocious
guard dog
and and and yet
because he's also like
bored um dead ended
and potentially also has that kind of
revelation that sting had
of like oh my god i can see the whole
rest of my life
and i'd really rather shoot myself than
go down that path so
there's something
that awakens
a rebellious streak in him an
adventurous streak
um a kink
you know just a fascinating fascination
with this
young woman and
it's almost like
an opportunity presents itself
to break out of jail
so
it's kind of a wild streak in this
character
it's almost like a tiger that's been
raised in a zoo
and is domesticated in a lot of ways get
its food delivered to it
all that stuff but some of its
wild instincts arise
and it has a
profound hunger to pursue that
and and
the thing to also bear in mind that as
i'm playing with this this is
wildly unformed in my mind
so that i'm literally
sitting here with
a couple things in my hand and nothing
else
uh so i can see how to amplify
that part of him that is no way you're
getting around me
over my dead body but then
what i'm also looking at and i got that
that's not going away that's
not so hard we can probably complicate
that
as the story progresses or we'll stumble
over
ways that are obvious that we haven't
noticed yet to make that
even stronger but that's not
complicated from one point of view this
is an
interesting puzzle to make this side of
the dilemma
more unacceptable more powerful more
dynamic
and so all the reasons why he can't let
go
of the opportunity that she presents
including her he's just
fascinated with her as a possible mate
even if he's already married or maybe
his marriage is dead and who knows
that these are all things to play with
as you play what if with the dilemma
but
that part of him
you know for instance like a crazy what
if like what if
like in lethal weapon he goes home and
puts a gun to his mouth and is thinking
about suicide like he's so
dead end in this job and hates it that
maybe he's attempted suicide before and
nobody ever knew
i don't know maybe he just plays with
the rifle with a handgun at home
that would complicate
it gives him more of a flaw which you
tend to want to have
and complicates his
approach to
the riddle that she presents for him
internally
um i think that clearly if he's great at
his job
that he has several different options
like he could just
shut her out and walk away and there but
then there's no
dilemma there's no story but that's one
of the options
once he begins to notice what she's up
to he's like
i'm out of here you know screw you i'm
how how why would you do this to me and
you're not my friend and
we're not going down this road and he
just pulls the plug and it's done
maybe they got into a little bit of
something and he just covers it back up
or changes something and
what they got didn't amount to anything
and he just
drops the firewall on them but what
you're suggesting
is quite a bit different than that
is that that that part of him which is
starving for some fresh air
can't let go of this opportunity and
won't
and even if it ends up
that he ultimately goes over to the dark
side and completely betrays his company
and that gets him out of his
trap you know it's like the bear chewing
its leg off to get out of a leg hold
trap
that may be one of his options or
that may be
see there's one thing to be trapped in a
good strong dilemma
and that generally kicks in around the
end of act one after we've gotten to
know the character
and get the story developed to a point
that dilemma builds an intensity all
throughout act two
until around the end of act two it comes
to a critical juncture
where it comes to the make or break
point because with dilemma
you really can't choose either way like
jake in training day
cannot let go of his ambition and cannot
let go of his moral compass
and the crisis in training day
comes when alonso tries to have him
killed by the hillside gang the latino
gang
in that house up on the hill and they're
about to blow his brains out in the
bathtub
i'm not going to say anything more about
the story because i don't want to spoil
it for people who haven't seen it
but that's part way through it i'm not
going to talk about the ending at all
but that crisis
forces a decision in action about the
dilemma
so that the crisis demands an immediate
decision
and action about the dilemma that the
protagonist is
still stuck in
and the protagonist
once the dilemma comes to this critical
juncture the crisis which is out around
the
three-quarters point in the story the
protagonist
has to make some kind of decision and
take some kind of action
that breaks the paralysis of the dilemma
so they're now in a fight to the finish
to try to resolve the dilemma
so as i'm wrestling
with derek's dilemma and looking at
amplifying it making it more powerful
more riveting to the audience
and part of that is playing crazy what
if that's what i'm talking about like
don't settle for the easy choices how
far can you take it
how much can you make this protagonist
scream because of this dilemma
the more impossible it is for them
the more the audience comes up on the
edge of their seat because this is
our hero in this story and they're
caught in a bad situation
and if that dilemma is universal which
you tend to want to do
then the audience is sitting there going
i
understand this dilemma because i'm
caught in something like this
you know of like a duty versus honor
dilemma
or whatever that may not be i
that's not necessarily and that's
probably not
a good description of this particular
dilemma
but let me let me so let me retract and
articulate his dilemma with that level
of simplicity so
duty and honor is definitely there no
way
they're getting around me but no way
am i letting go of this
whacked out left-handed opportunity
that blindsided me and reawakened
my starvation for adventure and freedom
and unpredictability so really it's a
security versus adventure dilemma
which is very universal like
no way am i letting go of my security
but there's no way i'm letting go of my
adventure
it's like it sucks being a bank teller
but it sucks trying to make it as a
painter living on peanut butter
sandwiches
i can't let go of the security but i
can't let go of my need for adventure
so i i think that's an accurate
representation at first glance
of derek's dilemma so
his and i would say that he has a part
of his personality makeup is a
deep-seated
need for security and predictability
and to be a good watchdog but there's
also the contradictory part of his
personality
that's starving for adventure and fresh
air and
to get out get out of that cubicle and
start really living life
so not only
does skyler
and her masters
present
an unexpected opportunity
but that the deeper
derrick gets in as you progress through
act two
and this dilemma gets more and more
intense
as things keep ratcheting up that it
becomes
more acceptable to let them
get around him but it's also more
acceptable
more unacceptable to let go of this
dynamic
once in a lifetime opportunity
and you know and some of that would
probably have to do with
the nature of the business that business
that he's protecting and
the intentions of
the uh predator who's operating
skyler and and you know those are things
to play with for instance is the company
that derek works for maybe the more
derek is exposed
to what skyler is talking about and
probably
what her boss is telling her to say
maybe derek begins to perceive that the
company he's
vigilantly protecting is actually either
a criminal operation
or is doing something morally
reprehensible
that makes this side stronger
but maybe what they're going to do with
it is
highly questionable or criminal or
whatever so the need to protect
so there's there's story possibilities
that can go
in wildly different directions
[Music]
and you know so much of that has to do
with
your intention as a storyteller where
you want to steer the story
versus listening to the story like
it basically comes down to
what the tools that you're using as a
dramatist
suggest in terms of story possibilities
and dramatizing the material so that it
stays active and gripping to an audience
there's like there's like the demands of
the story and the demands of the tools
and you want to really listen to both of
them
the tools will suggest certain things
the story will suggest certain things
and you want to really
factor them both in like
the the um
the technique the techniques of the
various tools involved may suggest that
you steer the story in this direction
but your intention as a storyteller
or as the story takes on a life of its
own it may really want to go in this
direction
and you want to really be responsive to
that
the story is the most important thing
the tools are mere technique that can
help you shape the story to
make it work dramatically
so it's a given take between
what the story the energy that the story
brings to the table and your intentions
for what the story brings versus
the technique that you bring to the
table
so it's kind of like a synthesis of the
two
and so
you know as i
work with
making the dilemma more and more intense
and riveting and entertaining or
compelling
you know it may be a brutal thriller so
it's not like an action comedy at all so
entertainment value is absolutely like
how's this gonna turn out i can't look
away
somebody's gonna die here you know it
can be brutally intense and
really riveting so it's not like
entertainment value and like haha
funny but it's just like they couldn't
pay you to
to leave the theater before it ends
um so that
as i build that dilemma toward
the the critical juncture around the end
of act two when that dilemma
becomes a crisis and forces an immediate
decision and action
about that dilemma now that it's gone
critical
it's like a gun to the head that demands
you don't you don't
get to contemplate your dilemma from a
distance anymore
going what am i going to do when
it goes critical now it has gone
critical and it's like the gun is to the
head
and you got to make a decision right now
and take an action
and you're like i can't make a decision
so that's
it's it's riveting but as i'm
amplifying the dilemma what i'm looking
at is the point on the horizon that it's
all going to converge
toward at the two-thirds point around
the end of act two
that what does not what does
what is shaping up as the potential
crisis as i build the dilemma
in other words there could be a whole
lot of factors
that go into constituting the crisis
which informs the trajectory of the
dilemma
because often a crisis is all the worst
possible stuff happening at the worst
possible moment
and sometimes the crisis can involve
that you're
it's not like all catastrophic failure
all at the same time
which is definitely part of a crisis
where everything's caving in
on you at the worst possible moment but
it can also be like that you're
right on the edge of succeeding right as
it all goes to hell
you're like i'm an inch away from
pulling this off i had a way out i can
do this
and it all cascades into failure so it's
not all just
it's all going wrong but part of it it's
all going right and this is the worst
possible thing at the worst possible
moment
so it's a mixture of the two and it's
so as i build the dilemma
the possibilities for the crisis inform
the choices that i'm making
because it's like how can i make this as
gripping as possible
as it gets denser and more complex and
more compelling
and that's where you know like what i'm
talking about about don't make
sedate choices you know it's about
entertainment value about
it's about outrageousness and
that doesn't mean just mere
wacky stuff or blowing more things up
but it's like
as he wrestles with his dilemma as
things get more and more intense
she i would think is
perhaps flowering as a person
in their relationship that she's like
the best thing that ever happened to
him but she may also be the worst thing
that's ever happened to him like she's
creating him she's turning him into a
new person but she's also destroying him
so that he can't hang on and he can't
let go
and she's like wildly the love of his
life
but he still can't jump ship because
he's gonna
lose his life maybe in the process of
making his life
so it's an aggressive experimentation
with
pure storytelling and pure technique
and synthesizing the two where the
technique
suggests ramping up the intensity more
and more and more
until it's at the like it's like at a
point of
the engine is screaming and about to
vibrate to pieces
and then everything really goes wrong
at that like at the worst possible
moment
a whole other monkey wrench gets thrown
into the thing
so it's all like playing with options
um is that helpful
yeah i love it i love it and i'm
wondering is there something that's just
dilemma
that's just one part of one of the seven
tools
but that's where i go first right and
i'm wondering what
where could like a meteor come from
another plant and just like
just destroy all expectations because we
figured there's probably going to be two
outcomes one of two either he's able to
quote unquote save her
and give her this good life maybe she
never had and that's why she would
do such a thing and she needed the money
and she got in with some bad people
or um he's going to he has such a strong
moral compass that he's going to say
sorry i can't do this i not only am i
going to ruin my career
but my parents and all my high school
friends and college friends they're
never going to see me the same
and i'm going to end up in the papers
and so but then
what could be a third thing that could
just come from nowhere that we don't see
because those seem like two likely
outcomes well there's
two avenues to explore in that question
one of which has to do with um
informal logic they talk about dilemma
as being caught on the horns of a
dilemma
two equally unacceptable alternatives
either one will gore you you
can't you can't go either way and
they talk about different ways to
resolve a dilemma one is that you can
pick one of the horns
or the other you can pick one of the
unacceptable alternatives
and go all the way become a
revolutionary with her
destroy the company that he was in or
throw her to the
and become a more rigorous
guardian of the he could he could go he
could pick one of those two
unacceptable alternatives and go all the
way with it and resolve his dilemma
or by thinking on his feet he could come
up with a radically third alternative
in which he's not choosing either one of
the things that he was trapped in
it's like somebody saying you got to go
through that door or you got to go
through that door
and by thinking on your feet you get a
chainsaw and
cut a third door and go out that way
it's about it by thinking on your feet
you come up with a creative resolution
they call it the third path
in the science of dilemma
and so often in a story like this
the protagonist does
find a third way out
there's a great example of that in the
firm
but let me just say spoiler spoiler
alert
and if you don't if you haven't seen the
firm which is a phenomenal movie
hit pause fast forward a little bit
because it's a great example but i don't
want to ruin the movie for people either
so in in the firm tom cruise is in this
high-paying law firm and he finds out
it's actually
owned by the mafia and he gets put in a
good strong dilemma
by ed harris this aggressive fbi agent
who says
you have to um bring
us proof that they
are involved in a criminal enterprise
or we are gonna ruin your life
and if he brings proof then he violates
his
oath as a lawyer if he does what the fbi
wants he'll be permanently disbarred
because he divulged client
privileged information but if he doesn't
do what they're saying
they'll ruin his life it's something
like that i
i don't know if i'm saying it exactly
right but it's very much in the ballpark
he finds a creative third way out
in that when
he when one of the people he's working
with
mentions that they have been
systematically over
billing him which they're doing to
everybody and they make a lot of money
on that and it's criminal
the guy that he's the client that he's
talking to says what they don't realize
is when they put a stamp on this
that became a federal crime and tom
cruise's lies light up and he's like
yes and each single act is is punishable
by
you know ten thousand dollar fine and
ten years and each one of those and
he goes i just studied that for the bar
exam and he's like
and so what he does he
he does not do what the fbi demands of
him but he does not go down with this
criminal law firm
either is that he gives the fbi
proof of them systematically over
billing the clients
through the mail each of which is a
federal crime
and it wasn't this huge bust that the
fbi wanted
but a lot of little busts that have real
teeth and add up to a lot of prison time
but it's a lot of hard work for the fbi
but he gave them
by the letter of the law what they were
demanding without violating
attorney-client privilege
so he skated between these two equally
unacceptable alternatives by coming up
with a radical third alternative
that result that's that conclusively
resolved his dilemma
and made for a satisfying ending to the
movie
and so that would be the type of thing
that could work
very well in this type of story
so that for instance if for instance
there were some questionable activities
that his
the organization that he's guarding is
involved with
and the predator wants to get at that
it's kind of like
the predator is putting him in an all or
nothing position
but he finds a way
to maybe
undo some of the questionable activities
that his
the organization that he's guarding is
involved with
without violating them without
exposing their hard drive it merely
opens up to public scrutiny one thing
that they're doing
that they really shouldn't be doing
doesn't and allows the predator to make
that public
without hurting the company so he kind
of skates between
the trap that he's in and maybe takes
the girl with him
as a mate something like that in which
he finds a creative
third way out of the impossible
situation that he was stuck in
i like that so he's this that's the door
that he's
right okay and by thinking on his feet
he came up with a
creative third resolution
possibility where there used to be only
two because maybe
this this sort of um
this this act of espionage that they
want them to do is because maybe
they've compiled information on their
customer base and they really shouldn't
have kept that and not disclosed or
something so what if he somehow
i don't know turns it around so that
that that's no longer there or
then the customers are notified every
somehow it's like there's a resolution
i don't know how that would be done
should also be something of magnitude
if it's if it's a minor offense then the
audience will go so what who cares
so that's where the magnitude where you
it gets up to a level of like oh that's
important i care about that
right but that's just a factor you know
that's something to factor in
as you build that half of the dilemma
and it's informed by if the if the
predator who's operating the young woman
is showing him things that are
questionable about the organization
he's guarding and he's like yeah you're
right
they are you know but you just want it
to
come above a certain threshold of
questionability
right so don't that's all the
particulars of the story
sure so so forge the third path that
sounds like
don't take the right don't take the left
try to dig
that's just one possible resolution for
this type of story
well it would probably be too
predictable don't you think if if
i chose one or the other if i chose it
where somehow he
turned these people in and was able to
to
still keep his job and then he marries
her and they live happily ever after in
the suburbs
and and i mean that's i don't know if
that's really going to work
um or if he absconds with her to
the cayman islands and then he's hiding
for the rest of his life
that's not going to work either so right
or you know
he he escapes
the substantial trap that the predator
laid for him
and escapes the trap
of his um
rut his career predictable career rut
and
potentially some criminality that his or
that the organization he's guarding was
involved in
so that he kind of outsmarts
his boss and outsmarts the predator and
maybe
runs away with the girl and they
hitchhike around the world i mean like
he completely drops out of
the whole arena he was in you know it's
just
a part of a creative
a a possible creative solution
to the complex trap that he was stuck in
and he becomes a consultant that does
like white hat pen testing types
or he may never look at a computer again
they may steal a sailboat and
sail off you know with a hundred
thousand dollars in cash
in the hold and that's all they have but
it's he's completely free from
everything
there's you know there's so many ways
you can go with the story ending
but you wanted to impact the audience
powerfully and
make them
feel different than the way they came
into the theater
you know they want to be transformed
even transfigured
even like to the point where they never
think the same way again for the rest of
their life it like
permanently changes how their brain is
wired that's what people hope for
in a great story that it completely
changes how you see the world forever
most stories don't do that but the best
ones
can do that
and it's fun to aspire to what do you
believe is one of the most powerful plot
construction tools currently in the film
industry
the one that i teach is
called it's a three-step process called
sequence proposition plot
that was invented by william thompson
price but
was um sat undiscovered in his book
until i found
it
i've taught that to development
executives at all the
hollywood studios and they consistently
say it's the most advanced development
tool in the film industry
it's really powerful and it's unlike
anything that's out there
and it's a very sophisticated
tool for both plot construction and
story development
it um works with reverse cause and
effect
and
structuring compelling conflict
so that it's as i was saying before
with making the overall
story work first and then making each
act work in each sequence and each scene
it's you it's used for that because
the first the first step sequence is
reverse cause and effect it's the
sequence of cause and effect
that constitute the spine of the story
the forward progression of the story so
that
using reverse cause and effect you have
to have the
mechanics of the story sketched out
first you can't
do plot construction until you have a
story reasonably well figured out
um so that
with reverse cause and effect you start
at the ending
and work backwards so that you're you're
looking at the ending and you're
chaining back
from each effect to its cause so you
look at the ending and say okay well
what would be the immediate cause of
that ending
and you find the cause of that and then
you say okay what would be the immediate
cause of that
and the cause of that and so on and
so that
say it's a
it's a um
say it's a story about a uh someone
who's being muscled by a
mafia don no someone who's being muscled
by a
corrupt cop and
the corrupt cop puts him in a good
strong dilemma
and there's no way out and it gets worse
and worse and worse
and this character finally
figures a way out and that he makes a
deal
with a mafia don to set up this corrupt
cop because the mafia don wants to take
out this corrupt cop
so the character sets a trap so that
the crooked cop shows up to like rob him
at the
at the key point and the mafiadon swoops
in and takes him out
so the ending would be that the guy
is free from the trap he was caught in
before
you'd say well what would cause him to
be free it's that the mafia don
snatches the crooked cop and disappears
him
the cause of that would be that
the crooked cop swoops in to steal the
loot
the cause of that is that he sets up
the heist the fake heist to lure the
crooked cop in
the cause of that is that he makes the
deal with the mafia dawn
so when you play that and that's all
right
dense part of the ending but you could
see the cause and effect there where
he makes the deal with the corrupt mafia
don which causes him to be able to
set up the crooked heist which causes
him to have the the loot which causes
the crooked cop to swoop in and take it
which causes the mafiodon to be able to
grab
the cop and disappear which causes them
to
walk out of the trap that he was in so
it's
it's a way of of
not only stitching together
the the story components by cause and
effect but
actually
creating that cause and effect where it
may not exist
in other words if you have your story
roughed out and you start doing reverse
cause and effect and you start
chaining backwards through from each
effect back to its cause
you may get to a point where there isn't
a cause in what you've figured out so
far
and that may be a hole in your plot and
the logic of the plot and you say well
what would cause that to happen
and you may come up with a bunch of
different possibilities find the one
that works and
so then you have the next cause and then
what's the cause of that
so not only are you
knitting it together as you build
backwards you're taking what you've
already got
a story that's that you've sketched out
but you're now
it's like it's like the um
when when you've designed a project and
you know exactly what you want it to do
then you bring in the engineer and say
okay make
all the nuts and bolts of this actually
work here's exactly what we want but you
got to do the engineering
so we know how heavy the steel has to be
how much concrete to pour
and they'll give you hard numbers of
like you need
this much concrete and this much steel
so there's one thing of what you want to
achieve
there's another of the engineer comes in
and makes it all
tells you what to do to make it all work
it's that kind of thing
that as you take the story you've
roughed out
and stitch it together engineer it that
you actually
create the cause and effect as you build
and the trick to that tool is that you
are
asking at each point only what is the
cause
of that effect rather than what happens
before it
because any number of things can happen
before it but only one thing actually
caused it
so that's a way to help separate the
necessary from the unnecessary
it what it does is it frees you from the
profusion of unnecessary detail
the unnecessary kills scripts and that's
one of the things i was saying
i've trained a lot of um creative
executives
in at the you know the studios in
hollywood
in this tool and when i talk about
separating the necessary from the
unnecessary they're all going
yes you know the unnecessary overburdens
everything dialogues overwritten scenes
that shouldn't be there
whole acts which they're bombarded by
the unnecessarily constantly
it's one of the major symptoms they see
of that scripts don't work the dialogue
doesn't work
the spine of the story doesn't work
because there's too much there's
you don't have the what's necessary and
there's too much of the unnecessary it's
a
combination of the two so
what merely happens before an event
could be any number of things
the thing that actually causes it is
going to be among
those things that happens before it but
you're finding
the the key links you're basically
you're you're creating a chain
as you work backwards and when you
create the chain for the overall story
the chain of events
and you've rigorously included only that
which is necessary to the forward action
of the story
and you've rigorously excluded that
which is
unnecessary to the forward progression
of events that constitute the spine of
your story
then you've assembled it backwards out
of your
what the material you have and when you
find holes in your plot you invent to
fill them in so you're not only
structuring it but you're also
developing it you're creating when
needed
then when you read it from the bottom up
a causes b which causes c which causes d
and so on
that's the spine of your story whereas
before you had
a lot of clever elements to a story and
it looked like it worked but you hadn't
done the engineering on it to make sure
it really
worked and
being able to stand back and look at
your story
like it starts here and it moves all
through here it also enables you to get
a good objective look
at what you've created so far and
it's not easy to get a good objective
look at something you've been deeply
immersed in for a while
because this plot construction comes
after you've done a lot of creation and
development then you have to stitch it
all together into something that
actually holds water
so when you stand back and look at it
you may go oh there's the whole
spine of the story in simple terms and
you may go
well that's much better than i thought
it was going to be or you may go
god that really sucks i thought i had
much more than this but there it is
and i gotta like and you know
it's it's it's it can it can be not
working for you in any number of areas
or you may go you know i always thought
there was a
some kind of problem in act two but i
couldn't put my finger on it but boom
there i see it right there and you can
see
that part of it is distinctly weak and
it could be
so much stronger and so you know maybe
you fix it in an afternoon or maybe it's
three weeks or maybe it takes a month
maybe you have to read a couple great
books or talk to somebody who really
lived
it and then you come back and stitch it
all back together again
and then look at it again and go much
better but this
one piece is still weak so you're
evaluating
developing structuring and it's all in
the process of
plot construction
so once you've done
the the sequence that's the sequence of
events that
the overall story consists of just the
big picture
then so that's sequence out of sequence
proposition plot
three-step process so the second step
comes from price's proposition that we
were talking about before using logic
to pull all the story elements together
into a coherent whole
like we were talking about how pulp
fiction has
three different stories in it
but tarantino did an excellent job of
pulling those all together into a
coherent hole
it's not a mess of different stuff it's
one thing
that happens to be done in an unusual
way but it's still
perfectly crafted from a dramatic point
of view it's it's extremely effective
dramatically
and great storytelling has got both so
once you've got this tight chain of
events then
you set up a set up a conflict
set up a potential conflict early on in
the story
touch off a fight to the finish later in
and what price said is instead of doing
a and b therefore c
he said central to our job as a
dramatist
is to have the audience up on the edge
of their seat at the point
when the fight to the finish has only
just started
and they don't know how it's going to
turn out so at the point when
the fight to the finish has only just
started
the audience comes up on the edge of
their seat like how's this going to turn
out
because we've got a powerful proactive
protagonist
and we've got a powerful proactive
antagonist and we genuinely don't
genuinely don't know
who's going to win how it's going to
turn out and
so you set it up you touch it off you
get the audience on the edge of their
seat and you've either got the audience
or you don't
in terms of dramatic power on a scale of
1 to 10
how much are they on the edge of their
seat
if it's really powerful then you're
going wow yes
this i set it up i touched it off and i
really got the audience
if you set it up and you touch it off
and you can see it's still
kind of weak or it's actually quite weak
that's the power that's what the
proposition is for so you can propose it
take an objective look at it and then
evaluate it and then revise as needed
if it's only like a 7 out of 10 and
you're like no it needs to be i need a 9
or a 10
in terms of a scale of 1 to 10 for how
powerfully
i have the audience on the edge of their
seat at this point when the
when what the whole story is built up to
is unresolved
then you amplify different aspects of it
to get the audience that much
more on the edge of their seat so you're
you're creating a tight sequence of
cause and effect
then looking at the core conflict in the
story because it's really just
two boxers in a ring fighting it out
it's two dogs fighting over a bone
only one of them is going to walk away
in the end in fact the oldest greek
drama was only two characters on stage
the introduction of the third character
by sophocles was considered a major
innovation in drama
so the ability to see the core of your
plot as
two main
fighters in a fight to the finish and
only one of them is going to walk away
helps you get right at the core of what
makes your story work dramatically
so sequence is
the reverse sequence of cause and effect
that makes it tight
this you set it up you touch it off you
get the audience on the edge of their
seat
unresolved and if you're doing your job
right
the question in their mind about how
it's going to turn out is
really powerful then you've got
as much dramatic power as you can bring
to the to how you're dramatizing this
story
and then the last step is the
answering of the riddle the completion
of the action what how the fight to the
finish
shakes out in the back and forth between
protag and his antagonist
and who wins or loses in the end so
reverse cause and effect set up the
fight touch it off get the audience on
the edge of their seat
and wrap it up so that's sequence
proposition plot
and you do that once to the overall
story which makes it tight and dramatic
and well i'll explain that as i go along
then
as i said you break the overall story up
into acts like you literally
look at the chain of cause and effect
that you did in reverse
and you say okay that right there is the
end of act one
that right there is the end of act two
so you've got your axe so you take act
one
and now you do sequence proposition plot
to act one
so you start at the ending of act one
where it ends up
and you've already got like if you had
this chain of events
this part of it is act one so you've got
a chain of events right there that
constitute act one
you take that over here and you you so
you look at that
chain of events and you're going to
start at the end again
and work backwards through it and think
it through in a little more detail
so that you take what you've got
and you say okay so the like
the cop comes in and grabs the loot
and the mafia guy grabs him and
disappears him
so now you're gonna think that through
in a little more it now becomes
necessary
to figure it out in a little more detail
you didn't want much detail when you're
doing the overall story because you want
to just see
the main building blocks with nothing
else in there
because that's got to work and if you
get
swamped by a profusion of unnecessary
detail it can be hard to see the forest
for the trees
it can be hard to stand back and go wow
that chain of events is the whole story
you don't want extra you want it
stripped down so you can evaluate it now
it becomes necessary to think it through
in a little more detail it becomes
necessary
to layer in a little more detail so
you're thinking it through in a little
more detail of like okay so
is it like a bag of money or is it like
diamonds or is it somebody that he was
supposed to kidnap for the crooked cop
and how would what would the rough
mechanics of the trap
consist of like where would the mafia
guy be and
how do they make it so the cop really
puts his foot in the trap
even if there might be clues that he
might begin to suspect or he has good
instinct and he's like
something's wrong but he still puts his
foot in the trap
so you you
it becomes necessarily necessary to
figure out a little more detail
and then you chain backwards to that to
the to the
you you're looking at what you already
created
like what was the cause of that is that
he
does the actual heist that the crooked
cop wants them to do but there's some
falsehoods in it because it's a setup
how does that go down how does he do it
is the crooked cop watching
what is he taking is he swapping it for
something that's
a key part of the trap so you're you
don't you don't want
much detail because you you wanna it's
hard enough to figure it out and too
much detail
can just come up the works um
and then you go back to the next
you you look at what the next cause was
and think that through so what you've
done
is you may have like six causes that you
started out with that you brought from
the overall story and you've opened it
up a bit more so maybe now there's 12 or
something like that
so you expand upon what you already had
amplifying in detail
and you've got more then you throw that
act into a two-sided conflict where you
set up a potential fight
early on in the act touch off a fight to
the finish later in the act
get the audience up on the edge of their
seat about how the conflict in that act
is going to turn out
and then a completion of that action of
what's what's the rest of it
so you've done sequence proposition plot
so you've not only constructed
the story but you're literally inventing
your
story development as well you're
figuring out okay so what would actually
be in that bag that helps make the trap
work
but the cop doesn't see the switcheroo
or whatever
you're gradually developing those
details without getting into too much
detail
but you're you're literally fleshing it
out you're literally inventing
some of it you'll have the details
already figured out some of it you're
making up on the spot
and then you're creating conflict in
that act which there generally will be
some conflict
but you're really constructing it
setting up a potential fight touching
off a fight to the finish in that act
getting the audience out on the edge of
their seats so the act itself
has a high point of suspense at around
the two thirds three chorus point
that really gets the audience up on the
edge of their seat and then complete the
action so you've made it tight and
dramatic
then you do the same thing for act two
you expand upon the cause and effect
thinking
each step through in a little more
detail you
amplify whatever conflict is in that act
making sure you have a strong proactive
antagonist and protagonist
touch off a fight to the finish get the
audience on the edge of their seat
so act two really gets the audience on
the edge of our seat it's compelling
and and it's it you have a completion of
the action within that act
so now act two is tight and dramatic
then you do the same thing for act three
then you go back to act one and break
that into
sequences there are two to five
sequences in that act and you take
if this is the cause and effect for
act one then you say okay so if this is
the bottom
the beginning and this is the end so you
say okay so that much of it's going to
be
the opening sequence that much is the
next sequence that much is the next
sequence you take this chunk
bring it over here and think it through
in a little more detail
you expand upon it and open it up and
you're figuring out the mechanics of the
cause and effect for that sequence
and you're still rigorously excluding
the unnecessary and using
only that which is necessary to the
forward progression
of the action in that sequence and then
you structure the conflict
you set up a fight touch off a fight get
the audience on the edge of their seat
and resolve it within that sequence
so that sequence you've now flushed it
out thought it through
made it tight kept the unnecessary out
of it
and structured compelling conflicts so
that it gets the audience up on the edge
of their seat
two-thirds three-quarters of the way
through the sequence and then complete
the action
so you do that for each sequence in the
story maybe there's 12 to 15 sequences
in the story maybe some more
but that's a lot of work but so is 24
rewrites
so you're engineering your script
properly before you write it
so you do it for all the sequences
throughout the whole story
then you go back to the opening sequence
and you look at the cause and effect
you've got for that
and you break that into scenes you could
say okay this chunk of it is
the opening scene that's the next scene
and so on
so then you take that chunk of the
opening scene that's the cause and
effect that you've already figured out
and then you at the scene level you
think it through again you go
backwards through it visualizing it in
more detail what would be
now you're down to final detail what
would be the mechanics of who actually
does exactly what
and you're paraphrasing the dialogue so
now you've got
cause and effect for that scene and then
you structure the conflict in that scene
because you never want any part of your
story to go flat dramatically you don't
want
scenes that are mere information they're
mere narrative
you want the scene itself to be tight
and dramatic so
two-thirds three-quarters of the way
through the scene the audience comes up
on the edge of their seat
um so you made it tight and dramatic and
then you write that scene
then you do the same thing for the next
scene you
you do the reverse cause and effect
thinking it through in more detail
dramatizing it and then you write that
scene you go all the way through
writing each scene as you develop and
structure it
and then you have a working draft and so
that's the function
of sequence proposition plot as a plot
construction tool
it also happens to be very much a story
development tool
the two go hand in hand and glove
but it's a remarkably powerful tool
price constructed it
but didn't
complete it he explains it very clearly
but nobody else picked up on it
and you know i read a lot of his
students books and so on and they picked
up on proposition
and that really entered the the lexicon
of structural technique for the
dramatist
not widely but it's it's certainly known
um but none of his students were talking
about sequence proposition plot
his student who you know the two books
that i read for three years
that student student didn't even talk
about reverse cause and effect which
price went on and on and on about
so i was like how could they not be
seeing this but it was like
you know finding an old rusty tool out
in the field
behind da vinci's old workshop that had
just laid there for hundreds of years
and nobody ever
tripped over it and i found it and it
was like this works and i
combined it with what his students did
it really wasn't there price described
it
but didn't build it at all and he wasn't
even satisfied with
the proposition part of it but his
student did a lot of detective work
because he
knew that price had a remarkably
powerful tool but it died before he
wrote his next book and explained it so
he did a lot of detective work
and pieced together made the proposition
more sophisticated and powerful
and then this other playwriting teacher
made the proposition
work even better and i used all of those
and synthesized them together
so this was like an old tool that i
found
synthesized together with some of what
his students said and then i added to it
and then worked extensively with it for
many years
so it doesn't really exist anywhere
and when i started teaching people kept
saying
that they'd never seen anything like
what i teach and that it worked better
than anything out there
so
partly i didn't expose myself to other
dramatic writing teachers
because i didn't want to start pirating
what they were saying i wanted to just
stick with the with the uniqueness of
this
and it it works you know it's a complete
working technique
um but it's
it really is like nothing people have
ever seen
and it really works powerfully
and it's it's very much
plot construction uh one of the things i
say that's kind of fun
is um i only teach one thing
plot construction and dramatic principle
it's kind of a coan in a certain way
because there are obviously two things
but plot construction comes out of
dramatic principle
if you understand dramatic principle the
mc that
the underlying principles that make
dramatic structure work
then dramatic principle informs plot
construction they're
very much the same thing in the same way
that
medical theory informs brain surgery or
something like that
they're they're very much different
parts of the same animal
um okay so i hope that was clear
absolutely are both books required
reading or is one of them out of print
actually neither um
price's book is very dense reading
and hard slogging
his students book is really excellent
but i synthesized them to you could
definitely learn from reading them but
you can learn
more quickly from studying my book
writing a great movie because it
it's synthesized
uh a lot of their tools into a powerful
unit price's book is kind of like
walking through thigh deep mud it's not
it's hard
slogging and it's it's a lot of work
um so
anybody can go find it it's it's easy to
find but it's
it's brutally hard work
and you won't find what's in my book
in those books in a lot of ways
we've been talking a lot about the
unnecessary and how it kills
scripts and you said how 98 possibly
even 99 point
whatever five percent of scripts are
totally unreadable it has to do
with both storytelling and
scriptwriting craft because
a great story that is not stage worthy
doesn't work in theater they have this
term they say it's a great story
but it's not stage worthy yes it sounds
great around a campfire
but we can't perform it on stage in a
way that will grip an audience
so you can have the best story in the
world but if it's not
if it doesn't work dramatically then it
doesn't make a good script
and you can have phenomenal craft as a
dramatist but if your story
is poor then it's mere structure it's
just well-structured crap
it doesn't do you any good either so a
lot of stories fall
a lot of scripts that don't work fall
into those
two broad categories they do that the
underlying story
is weak or has been done to death
or any variations on why the story
itself doesn't work
or that the
structure of the story does not lend
itself
to being performed theatrically
as a film tv show or stage or even
dramatic content these days
and the unnecessary
is a big part of that because
the unnecessary crops up everywhere
it's the profusion of unnecessary detail
is always swirling around a story
it's it's a lot like
in at nasa they talk about
launch weight like a rocket
is engineered to
only lift a certain amount of weight of
payload
with the amount of rocket fuel that's on
board
and it's a it's an escalating problem
where if the
weight of the rocket if if what's being
brought on the rocket gets heavier then
you need more
rocket fuel to hoist it which makes the
whole rocket heavier
so you need more rocket fuel it kind of
exponentially
so they're ruthless in terms of what
gets on that rocket ship
and so
because they have to have the launch
weight has to
be what they say it has to be because
it's been engineered
right down to the last liter of fuel
that's on board
so in the same way that part of
your storytelling person
is saying i need this to go in the
script two
it may sink it it may
just be too much for it part of what it
is
is that it has to do with the forward
progression of the story's action
and what the audience is actually seeing
there's a chain of events
that constitute a scene or a sequence or
an act or the overall story
and that's what is necessary
to make that script work and
if you try to add something in that is
not necessary if you go off on a tangent
then you may
you can well lose the audience
lose the audience's um being on the edge
of their seat
if it if if you're following a chain of
action
each cause creates an expectation in the
audience of like okay so now what's that
going to cause
and then the effect of that happens
which causes the next effect
and so if you put a cause in motion
and the audience is on the edge of their
seat wanting to know what comes
next and you wander off on a tangent
then the audience is going no where's
the thing come on come on
and and it's it can become flat
dramatically or dead dramatically or you
just
lose the audience and and
if you lose the audience then the
dramatic power of the material
fades it's one of the things one of the
reasons why a script
doesn't work or why you know an actual
movie or tv show or stage play doesn't
work
so it has to do with
the stripped-down nature of dramatic
writing
it's a lot like dipping a fish in acid
and pulling out just the bones
that's the bones are what make the story
work
and as i was
i've known this before but the the
showrunner i was telling you about said
it well
she said once you strip the plot
down to its just
pure metal on metal bones
that gives you the flexibility
to do something creative with it to
to play around a bit because it's a very
tight rigorous structure
so you can you have room to layer in a
little color to let it breathe
to let it move it's like a jazz musician
where
you know we're going to play a b sharp d
so you know what you're doing but you
can still improvise around it
and kind of breathe life into it you're
still following the structure
but you all there's also room to
improvise because it's so stripped down
and that allows it to breathe so it's
not mechanical
or anything it's it's alive
and so
it's not so much what's unnecessary
it's what's necessary and if
you have if you're a good storyteller
and have great craft as a dramatist
then you know what's necessary to make
the story work dramatically
and that's what's important if you're a
rocket scientist and you can't make the
damn thing
fly then you don't know what's necessary
so there is really only what's necessary
everything else is unnecessary
some of those unnecessary things can be
little details that add flourish and
flavor
and color and breathe life into it but
most of it is distracting extra stuff
extra baggage
it's like handing a sprinter a backpack
with 40 pounds of books in it
it it will not work but that's what
people are often trying to do
because they either don't have the craft
to understand that which is necessary
to make the story of their grandmother's
escape from a concentration camp work
dramatically because they're so attached
to everything that happens in the story
they want to put everything in but
they're
bringing their rock collection onto the
rockets it's about to take off
and no this was my grandmother's rock
collection and it has to come with me to
the moon and they're like
not in a trillion years are you getting
that pile of rocks
into this launch pad and so
that they're they're ruthless about what
gets on that rocket and not
and writers have to be the same thing
that's why they talk about kill your
darlings
that kind of thing it's once you
understand
the mechanics of what's necessary to
make your story work dramatically
then almost everything else is
unnecessary
and you're constantly combating it it
reminds me of a
an old uh
tom swift's story from when i was a kid
he was an inventor
and he invented this device that
expelled water
so he could go to the bottom of the
ocean and turn it on
and he would make a bubble the size of
this room and he was you know
deep and he was on the bottom working
and there was no water and it literally
expelled the water in the same way that
it expels the unnecessary
there is nothing unnecessary allowed in
because you're
rigorously saying what is the cause of
that it's like
say that your sister calls you up one
morning
wakes you up out of a dead sleep and
goes hey hey i just had this crazy dream
that you won the lottery and i mean it
was the most realistic dream
go buy a ticket and you're like no i'm
not sleeping no no
go buy a ticket right now you go buy the
ticket and you win
you're like whoa so the cause of you
buying that ticket is
she said you have to and
now the things that come before you
buying that ticket might be that
you get a parking ticket you buy a
coffee you get some cigarettes
all that stuff comes before you buying
the ticket but the cause of you buying
your ticket
is she demanded that you do so so
you're looking at the cause of an event
rather than what merely happened
before it and the things that merely
happen before
it may or may not make it into the
script
but only if they
see there's the overall story where the
big bones of the action
are set up first and then you figure out
the bones of the action required to make
it work at the act level so you layer in
a little bit more
but cause strict cause and effect so
nothing
you know so getting that parking ticket
may not be part of the chain of cause
and effect that
helped you get to the store and get the
ticket and then at the sequence level
you know maybe that parking ticket is
part of the chain of events that is
necessary
or it may not get in at the c scene
level you're inventing a little more
but there's things that never get into
the story it's like when you make a suit
there's a pile of cloth left around it
on the floor at the end
you've got a suit and there's a whole
bunch of stuff that didn't get into the
suit
so it's about
that which is necessary and only that
which is necessary
and rigorously stripping out the
unnecessary
why are extremes necessary in story
it has to do with audience demand
audience demand is a very powerful
factor that
the audience themselves are often
unaware of
audiences are very demanding
you go to the movies you end up paying
you know 100 bucks between the
babysitter and the parking and the
12 for a popcorn you know it's like
you want to go in there and want
something to knock your socks off you
can stay home and watch the paint dry
for free
you want whatever it is if it's a
romantic comedy you want to come out of
there
feeling really wonderful if it's a
horror story you want to be able to like
not go to sleep that night if it's an
action thriller you want to be tripping
on adrenaline when you come out of there
you want that you need it and the times
when you can
see audience demand most clearly is when
you
go into a movie and it doesn't deliver
what you wanted it to and look at your
response afterward it isn't like uh
too bad it's like i needed that
come on you know it's like so it has to
do
with the nature of the medium that it's
it's an entertainment medium it's the
movies it's a
great tv show it's a riveting play
and so extremes are just
one aspect of making a story
work so that it really
knocks the audience for a loop no matter
what genre it is
you know it can be a brutal thriller or
a wacko comedy but it still has to work
dramatically and it still has to
basically the final effect of any script
is the principal effect
it's like a it's like a magic spell or a
hypnosis
where it all comes together in the end
like in a hypnosis i've talked to you
for a while about blah blah blah blah
and then when i snap my fingers
you'll be a and boom and all of a sudden
it like crystallizes and you're like
and it's completed the transformation in
you
so the final effect the good powerful
ending
wraps up and delivers the entire power
of the story
into one power like the crack of a whip
where just the last bit of it actually
breaks the sound barrier
and that's where the the sound comes
from
so a a powerful ending
impacts the whole story extremes are
just
part of the recipe for
making the story itself great and
powerful
like we were exploring streams excuse me
we were exploring extremes
in the idea about the i.t guy derek
you know we were looking at his dilemma
and just exploring extremes as a natural
part of that how can we make
his dilemma as riveting as possible
so that's naturally part of that is
naturally exploring the extremes
so even in a really fun
romantic comedy like music and lyrics
with hugh grant and
drew barrymore
it's fun it's moving it's enjoyable
you fall in love with them they're
playing with extremes within the genre
and within the tone of this you don't
want to violate the tone of the story
so you're you're not turning a thriller
into a horror movie just to
expand into expand forever
it's a bubble you want to not violate
the tone of the story so you're always
conscious of
the context of the story and the
extremes
that work within the tone
and so on so it's really context
sensitive and it has a lot to do with
with the genre but it all goes back to
that the key word in the entertain
in the entertainment industry is
outrageousness
so whatever genre you're in
part of what you have to factor in is
that it really is
entertainment even if it's a
tragedy it has to be gripping and
compelling
and riveting
you know it's about getting the audience
on the edge of their seat
and about you know why do people go to
the movies what do people look for in a
great tv series
what do you hope for when you go to see
a play that's supposed to be great
which is a lot about audience demand
what happens when you combine
aristotle's dilemma
with the early teachings of a 1900s
playwright w t rice
yes he wasn't a playwright he was a
script doctor
and a playwriting teacher it was really
a process
of synthesizing them together
my playwriting teacher taught me the
basics of aristotle dilemma crisis
decision interaction resolution
and then gave me the price
the price book and his student's book to
read
so
essentially
they one doesn't
work without the other from from one
point of view
i've taught this for a long time and
i've thought a lot about how to teach it
and i've tried different things where i
only taught sequence proposition plot
but if you're
doing sequence proposition plot
to a script that doesn't have a good
strong dilemma
then the underlying material is weak
dramatically
so you're merely providing a tight
structure to something that is
that's underlying story is weak
dramatically it's kind of like
you've got to have good steel to make a
good sword so even if you have
know how to pound a sword into shape and
the steel is
poor then it still doesn't
work so it's
they're really
i kept thinking well i can just teach
small workshops
in different tools but
one is really indispensable to the other
and you know that's true of character
development
that your characters have to be deep and
complex and flawed and unpredictable
and familiar and
i get a lot of that from the enneagram
which is a personality profiling system
so that
in terms of synthesizing
the things that aristotle notice tend to
be common
to those dramas that grip an audience
dilemma crisis decision in action and
resolution
with the proposition and sequence
proposition plot
they are all very much
part of the same process that
your
it's kind of like
digging into the ground and finding
metal ore and smelting that ore and
refining it
and making that into a quality metal
that you can then build with
so that dilemma
it's all part of dramatizing your story
you got to have a good story idea to
begin with
and you tend to want to have your
protagonist trapped in a good strong
dilemma
and that dilemma
dramatizes the story it helps make the
story
more dramatically effective as you build
it
so you're constantly paying attention to
storytelling and the craft of the
dramatist so often
each part of the story that you add to
or amplify you're also paying attention
to
helping it work dramatically by
amplifying the power of the dilemma
making a better crisis
making a more compelling decision in
action a more satisfying
resolution to the dilemma a deeper more
complex character
[Music]
so that all of it
goes into the recipe and you've got to
have
quality ingredients
and good cooking skills
because poor ingredients
a great chef can have a hard time with
really poor ingredients
and the best ingredients can be lost on
someone who can't cook
so
that's essentially the nature of
synthesizing aristotle and price
together
among many other things
but it also goes back to like what i was
talking about of
learning how to juggle on a unicycle on
a tightrope
there's different individual
skills and you know the tools
and the underlying principles that make
those tools work
and you gradually learn one principle at
a time
and one tool at a time and then
synthesize them together
into a a
set of professional skills you know much
like a doctor gets in training where
there's a whole lot of
training that goes into their
overall professional capacity
and they they often
no longer see the seams between the
individual parts
because they've really been synthesized
into one
fluid professional capacity
what is the dilemma of magnitude
magnitude means
significance substance is it significant
to an audience
you tend to want to have a good strong
dilemma for your protagonist
but the dilemma can be
weak it may not pass what they call the
so what test
uh sam cohn the founder of columbia
pictures
used to run his development process like
this he would bring
his writers into a conference room
around a big long table
and he'd put his head down on the end of
the table and go okay what do you got
and the guy would pitch his side he'd be
go so what next
blah blah blah so what and and go around
the table and finally somebody be like
ah yeah that's got something that let's
work on that
so it's that kind of thing it's like it
has to pass the so what test you've
probably seen movies where
you're watching it and it gets going and
you're like
wait is that all this is come on
you know it's like or
they're telling you a story and
you can tell that
they want you to feel x y and z about
your main character but you don't and
you're like
i just don't care that's called trying
to dictate an emotional response it's
like i'm saying
you have to feel this way about this
character because i say so
and you're like i hate this person you
know it's like i don't i'm not invested
in them i do
and and that has a lot to do with like
magnitude
because if you are focusing on the
specific aspect of a good strong dilemma
for your protagonist
it really has to be strong it has to be
significant it has to be of substance
to the audience so that they're really
drawn into it
and that goes hand in glove with
universality too because
they say that the deeper you go the more
universal your story becomes
so that you could be writing a story
about
you know a goat's herd in ethiopia and
if you've got a really
deep compelling dilemma then a banker in
tokyo could be like
i'm caught in the same thing and a
fisherman in alaska could be like
i'm living that exact same dilemma of
like
honor versus duty or so you know what
it's like if the average person in the
audience
if it hits the average person in the
audience where they
live then they'll connect to it
and because if they don't care about it
then you've got nothing because it's all
about the audience
whatever your
whatever you're building into your story
has to connect to the audience and
get them up on the edge of their seat
and keep them there
so there's a number of different ways in
which you you have to get the audience
sympathy for the protagonist
and maintain it if the protagonist makes
a bad choice
or whatever then the audience can be
like ah i'm not rooting for that person
anymore i don't like that
i'm done like i don't care anymore so
you have to get it and keep it
and so magnitude is just one aspect of
that
it's like i was talking about their the
tools create certain distinctions
and you want to utilize those
distinctions as clearly as possible
because that's where you get the power
of the tools and magnitude of a dilemma
is one of those distinctions
what you don't want to do is muddy those
distinctions
every time they become inconvenient
because then you lose the power of the
tool
how does a writer know they have a good
strong dilemma
well so much of that comes with
experience with the tool
and knowing how to use it fully and
properly
you know it it's like you
see that in a doctor where their ability
to diagnose something that's tricky
has a lot to do with their training and
their experience
and their training often creates
instincts in them
where you know that maybe the professor
in medical school kept saying
never forget this you know you may never
see it in your whole career but
always look for it and so even if the
doctor doesn't even remember
that consciously part of their brain is
like going did i
check that box and if they actually do
then they're like
wait does it hurt when you sit up in the
morning and they're like yeah
what does that have to do my head hurts
like no no no okay we got to get you
into surgery right away
you know like they're they don't even
know where that came from but they like
their training is built into their
subconscious at a certain level
so there's a you know it depends on your
experience with the tool and all that
but you know that's a distinction
between
a deeply trained writer and one who is
solidifying their craft you know even as
you're solidifying your craft
that's a key thing to look for is the
strength of your protagonist's dilemma
because it's so central it's part of the
foundation of your story
so that you know
if you're building a skyscraper and
the foundation has been poured
you know you may get an engineer and go
around
and double check to make sure
that the concrete's set up as hard as it
was supposed to so you don't have weak
areas
in your foundation or that the
substructure beneath the foundation
isn't
weak or might collapse in a heavy rain
you really want to make sure
that the basic stuff you're going to
build on is really solid
because everything else that comes after
that is impacted if there's a weakness
in the
the first principles and the core things
uh one of my friends is a martial arts
teacher and he said that
by being a martial arts teacher for so
long
he had to keep focusing on first
principles because that's what he was
teaching a lot of times
just the most basic stuff but
he said after a while he realized that
it was making him
a much more substantial martial artist
because
the first principles are what everything
else is built on
and that that solidified his foundation
and i found that that was true too he
said they're first principles for a
reason they're the main
underlying components that everything
else
comes from so for instance
in i taught nonstop for 18 years in
these
small groups there were six people
maximum and each
i was working with each person on their
own script
so like if i explained dilemma
then i would go around the room and i
might start with you and say okay what's
your story idea
and i you know i explained dilemma i
showed how it worked on godfather
tootsie
blade runner things like that and then
you tell me your story idea that you
brought and i've never heard it before
so you may have you know some completely
wacko comedy that i'm like
wait let me get some coffee so i can
sharpen my brain here i have to like
wrap my brain around it and then look at
it i was like okay
is there a dilemma in the story and if
there is
can i i can feel one i can see one half
of it very clearly
i can feel the other half but i can't
put my finger on it and after a while
it's like oh
right it's that oh that's funny yeah
yeah you got a
a comedy with a dilemma that's funny
that's what you want like that's clever
and you may be saying i didn't know that
was in there
i'm like yeah but that that's my skill
with the tool enabled me to find it
and you're like wow yeah that's i love
that i didn't know that i had that in
there i was like well it
it was there you know but i've even i
have
substantial expertise in this skill it
took me a bit to kind of feel around in
the mud and be like oh that
wow look at that you know so it's like
skill and and familiarity with it
but in terms of a student knowing if
they have a good strong dilemma
part of it is experience and part of it
is just
rigorous technique trying to use the
tool
explicitly and to utilize all its
distinctions very clearly because they
have
the distinctions are there for a reason
and have great power
and dramatic writing is generally
considered the most elusive of all the
literary disciplines
it's tricky it's slippery it's hard to
pin down
um a script can work
three quarters of the way through and
then fall apart and nobody knows why it
fell apart and nobody can make it work
or
a script can have look great on paper
have all the top people
all the money in the world and it goes
out and
loses a hundred million dollars on its
opening weekend and the same
basic story shot for sixty two thousand
dollars in a shoe box and
you know with two actors goes on to win
best picture and
you know make a hundred million dollars
and they're like it's the same story
and we had all the top people and
everything
and they looked the same on paper but
there's
worked and i don't know why theirs
worked and i don't know why ours didn't
it it's slippery and so the ability to
use the tools
as rigorously and explicitly as possible
helps you to grab onto this slippery
thing
that like keeps spinning under your
touch and it's like i can't even pin it
down to
use the tool the more you can use those
distinctions in the tool kind of like
dragon talons
where you can grab this slippery marble
and make it actually
stop in place and really do like
serious surgery on it and like okay now
that may fix it because i had this
wobble and nothing we did made it work
but
i was able to really pin it down to get
down to real specifics with it
and all of a sudden like that part of it
seems to work better and yeah it helps
the whole thing
so it's part of it is just
pure technique and part of it is just
pure intuition with storytelling skills
and
seat of the pants making stuff up and
it's like mud wrestling it's like you're
down in the mud you can't even see half
the stuff and you're like i can't even
get these two to click
together you know it's it's not easy to
make a script work
and and that's why i keep saying you've
got to have huge
chops as a storyteller and you've got to
have serious craft as a dramatist
and you've got to really be able to
synthesize those two together
and the better you get at that the more
your scripts will tend to work
it's about being consistent a number of
writers
have a great first script and it's a big
hit
and they're the toast of the town and
everybody's hiring them
and they can't make their second script
work and they don't know why their first
script work
and they don't know why the second one
isn't working
and you know being able to be consistent
is is really important and so
it's a tricky business it's not easy and
you want to really have big muscles in
every department storytelling
craft as a dramatist character
development
all this stuff you gotta really be
hitting on all cylinders to have a
consistent career
are there any techniques a writer can
employ to generate
a great premise well yeah that goes back
to you know what i was talking about
like attack as a storyteller and
to you know have a sense of adventure or
even
depth because you know a sense of
adventure makes it sound like
you know you're writing some great
you know action comedy that knocks
everybody's socks off but a sense of
adventure can be like
a riveting drama or uh
you know a tragedy that no one will ever
forget for the rest of their life or
a completely hair-brained goofy comedy
you know that's like just off the deep
end so
it's just thinking big and
going for the roots of what makes people
tick
and what transforms people and what kind
of situations are compelling
and what has entertainment value and
what's been done to death
and what's fresh
so it's really a conglomerate
of attack as a storyteller
experience with what tends to work
reading constantly reading great scripts
and pushing the envelope but also
connecting with the average member of
the audience
you know one of the things i talk about
in terms of dilemma but it's applicable
in many different arenas is that
once you get your story up and running
and you've got something
you can go like okay here it is and it
can be dilemma or anything but
one of my fundamental questions is okay
now that i've got this up and running
one of the things i want to do is
in my imagination pick somebody that
lives down the street who might
be a plumber or an orthopedist or
a ceo of a company and like can they
connect to this story
because if your average joe
doesn't connect to the story you've
created
then it's kind of dead in the water in a
certain way and
you know one of the one of the key
things one of the intermediate steps in
terms of
looking at the person that lives across
the street and trying in your own
imagination to
say would they do they care about this
is looking at the way in which
how do you care about it and and
in what way does it grab you
and you may find well you know actually
if this main character
did this and this i would care a whole
lot more actually
and and being able to ground yourself
more in the material and the strength of
the material and the universality of the
material
that can help you then look at the
plumber down the street who's coming
into the movies on a saturday night with
his family
and expecting a fun ride or a riveting
adventure
and you know trying to make sure that
your average
joe can relate to it and care about it
and so on
so that goes into it too
i hope that answers your question it's
not an easy question because
it's different for every writer and
there are definitely
trip tricks and tips to doing that
but they're all just things that you
pick up as you go along and incorporate
into your process
so that you have the storytelling chops
to
be thinking adventurously no matter what
the genre
and the skill
the ability to turn a professional
critical eyeball
onto your material and go you know i had
fun creating it
and i think it's great but it's not
cutting it yet
so maybe it goes on the shelf or maybe
you just throw it away
jeff what is an enneagram and how does
it help a writer
create complex characters the enneagram
is a
really valuable tool it's a
personality profiling system that is a
mix of ancient wisdom about human nature
and cutting edge psychology i was
introduced to it
by a friend of mine who was a
top psychiatrist in new york city
and he was a good friend and he loved
movies so
he loved to consult on projects that i
was working on
so like if i was developing a script
with a client i would often bring him in
uh like one time i brought
the actor john leguizamo to him he was
working on
um a murder story
and he wanted some in-depth
stuff the kind of stuff that armand
could bring
and he met with armand and i talked to
john afterwards
and uh armand had sat him down
in front of police video
of a guy who had just murdered his
parents 45 minutes beforehand
this was real footage and john said oh
my
god it messed me up i was like i
couldn't sleep that night and i was like
whoa and i said well was it good
research it goes off
top shelf like off the charts crazy
and i worked with armand a lot that way
and at one point he said to me because
he was doing uh
character profiles on these at one point
he said to me have you ever
checked out the enneagram it's the best
thing out there
i'd never heard of it before and coming
from him he was
really brilliant and really at the top
of his game
and for him to say it's the best thing
out there i was like
whoa it wasn't like oh i think i'll
check it i was like boom i was like
right on it and i studied it intensively
for a couple years
and it what it it purports that there's
nine
basic personality types and
each of them has their own uh
basic fears basic desires motivations
preferences tendencies
weaknesses flaws and
there's all these different and not only
all that
but each of the nine types has
different aspects like they're either
a healthy aspect an average aspect or an
unhealthy aspect
and
depending on what
shape you're in emotionally and
psychologically
you are your life is either coming
together
you're you're integrating or your life
is falling apart you're disintegrating
and if you if you are
coming together as a person emotionally
and psychologically
then you will tend to exhibit the
average to healthy aspects
of the type you are
if you are falling apart as a person
then you will tend to exhibit the
average to unhealthy aspects
of that personality type
so it is a um
and they say that the average person
flickers between all those all day long
where you can have extremely healthy
reactions or actions in certain
situations or
extremely unhealthy and you flicker back
and forth all day long like real people
in and out of different emotional states
and so on
but you will tend to be what you are in
other words if you tend to be healthy
then most of your stuff will tend to be
average to healthy and it is a
so like the nine types are like
um they give them labels but they don't
use the labels very much type 1 they
call
the reformer type 2 is the helper type 3
is the achiever
type 4 is the individualist type 5 is
the thinker or the they have different
names
type 6 is the loyal list type 7 is the
enthusiast type 8 is the leader or the
challenger
type 9 is the peacemaker but
because each of those labels has certain
connotations with different people
the people who work with it
professionally they'll call you a one or
a four or a seven
because it's context free in a certain
way
the labels don't bring
their own misunderstandings to people
who are less
skilled in the application of the of the
technique
so that like a type three the achiever
can be very high performing it'll be
like a tony robbins type where they
really work hard to actualize all their
best capabilities tom cruise is a type
three
people who can really achieve great
things
push themselves to be the best they can
be and can really be extraordinary
but in the unhealthy or in the average
aspects
they can be really concerned with how
they appear
they're constantly wanting to look good
even if they aren't
doing well emotionally in the unhealthy
aspects they can
actively lie to look good even when
they're in really rough shape they're
really over concerned with how they
appear and will
do even devious things to maintain that
appearance
so that in the extremely unhealthy
aspects they can even be suicidal
or murderous to maintain the illusion of
their superiority or achieve
their achievements even if they're not
there
so
in terms of the
in both the creation of a character and
the development and dimensionalization
of a character
these the
the the basic human nature
which is built into the study of the
enneagram and
the cutting edge psychology which is
built into it
inform
what you both
find in your character and can
create in your character for instance if
i
like for instance going back to your
it guy derek and
the young woman skyler
i would one of the things i'd be looking
at and i'd be doing that once i get a
dilemma up and running
i'm also looking in the early stages of
developing a dilemma
for derek i would
go very quickly to which enneagram type
is he
because that's going to inform so much
who he is and how he interacts with his
dilemma and what his basic fears and
basic desires
and tendencies and motivations and
disabilities and flaws and blind spots
all of that inform not only what the
dilemma is
but how he will interact with it because
of his basic fears and drives and all
that
so let's see if i'm looking at him might
he be
a one or a former it's possible
two the helper maybe three the achiever
possible for the individualist
possible because he is an individualist
can be
uh intuitive artistic want to sort out
their own emotions before they deal with
anything else
uh possibly a type five um
a thinker a you know someone who is
perfecting things before they launch out
sherlock holmes was
a type 5 wants to have everything
like a type 4 wants to
figure out their emotional stuff before
they move ahead a type 5 wants to
figure out the mechanics of a situation
and have a lot of knowledge
because their basic fear is that they're
not well prepared
so they're protecting themselves so they
want to know everything before they
take a step so they spend too much time
figuring out before they take action
so they can be extremely world-changing
when they're on top of their game
and see things in a completely fresh way
but they can also be
paranoid and reclusive and dissociated
from who they really are because they're
desperately trying to
figure it all out in their head before
they do their debut
um so maybe he's a five he could be a
sixth the loyalist
which is lends itself to the i.t
who's the guard watchdog for this
mainframe and the whole company
the type one of the main motivating
factors in a type
six is they are
constantly hoping that the next person
they
latch on to is going to be the one who
can show them how to navigate
life successfully are you the one can
you
help me learn how to make my life work
which see that goes with the watchdog
for the corporation but also skyler like
are you the one that's going to show me
how to
make my life work finally so a six
is a possibility a four is a possibility
because
the um a four is
inwardly tuned has a lot of artistic
sensitivities
and a lot of inner debate
and wants to
make things work at an emotional level
uh i'm not describing it accurately
enough
but this is really an overview too but a
four is an interesting possibility
for derek a six is an interesting
possibility
a seven the enthusiast is the
busy fun-loving type which could be a
very interesting possibility
for uh skyler someone who's like
wildly enthusiastic the life of the
party
always busy a healthy seven is a lot of
fun
an unhealthy seven can be a drug addict
they're a constant escapist mode
a sevens main motivation
is to um in the unhealthy aspect of
their fears they wanna
they wanna what's the word kind of
dispel
unease they can't sit
and deal with
emotional complexity they want to escape
from it they
they don't have the the bone that
enables them to
sit there and figure it out they're in
escape mode a lot if they're average to
unhealthy
so they're always looking for the next
thing they're always planning even if
they've spent three months planning a
big cruise with all their friends
they can't enjoy the cruise because
they're busy planning the next thing
it's always about their plans
but they can be really fun to be around
and a healthy seven is really fun and a
really
healthy happy integrated person
so i would think that she's gonna be
pretty unhealthy
but they look dazzlingly fun
especially to someone who is feeling
miserable and trapped and caught in a
rut
and no way out so it's kind of an
interesting
chemical connection
where her malfunction
meshes with his malfunction in a way
that she looks like his savior
and he may look like her savior so they
sink on a lot of levels and
they fit each other's compulsive pattern
in a certain way
that even though it's an unhealthy
relationship they get a lot of mileage
out of it before the each realizes that
wow i'm back where i started or worse
because he's just as messed up as i am
in a completely different way
and we really screwed this thing up you
know it's that kind of thing
so in many ways it's a mixture of what
you bring
to the picture with your story and
what the enneagram offers as
possibilities
for character traits and
possibilities for character
you you when you come with your story
you have
a certain amount of something already
you're not coming with nothing and just
looking at the enneagram
for instance with the story of derek
you've already got a raw story and
we've done some work with dilemma so
you've got him
trapped and then if you find that
he seems like a type six enneagram
then the tendencies and basic fears
and all the things that make up a six
influence your story and your story
influences how you use those parts of
the enneagram
for instance if you're
looking at the mechanics of a type 6
and it offers some dynamic possibilities
for
what derek might be like as he
falls apart in a crucial moment of the
story
then that could really inform
the story choices that you make
and the story choices that you make can
inform what parts of the enneagram
you use or amplify or
play with you know so much of it is an
experimental
mix as you're really working with
everything
to gel
that which you decide to run with
one of the key ways that i use the
enneagram
is that if you've got
a story idea that's up and running
and you've worked on dilemma then
that's a point as as you begin to get
into dilemma for your protagonist
that's when it's very useful to look at
the enneagram because the
the character traits of
the type of your protagonist the
personality type
will inform and influence your
insight into the dilemma it can suggest
possibilities it can deepen and
dimensionalize
the dilemma and the way that i
tackle that is that i'll
have that character in mind like derek
and then i'll look at
the one sheet for each of the nine types
and those come
from the um enneagram institute.com
website i work with a slightly older one
sheet
from when i wrote my book around 2006.
it it fits on one sheet of paper and it
has a lot of information
what they have for their one sheet now
is they've expanded upon it
so there's more complexity which is
great
i just like going back to the one sheets
that are in my book writing a great
movie
because it's short and sweet then once
you've worked with that
you'll find the stuff on their website
which opens it up a little more
to be very useful too but what i do is
that i
think i put myself in the position of my
character or i think about my character
the lead character and look at the one
sheet for each of the nine types
and i'll sometimes just use my book or i
often i print out the one sheets because
i've saved them
and i'll look at a type one thinking
about derek and be like okay silver
former
there's some key aspects maybe a couple
on my underline that's a maybe
look at the two go through that three oh
that has more stuff that's interesting
four has some distinct possibilities
five and you know and maybe when i'm
looking at a five
well even while i'm thinking about
derrick i may notice that wow that could
really be
the the predator who's operating skyler
and it just jumps out at me like wow
there's there's that person
so you're just kind of like going
through
the nine one sheeps nine one sheets
mostly one character at a time but
sometimes other ones will just jump out
at you
and
so i found that i think derek really
seems like a six
and kind of like this you know as you're
looking through the one sheet a whole
bunch of stuff
starts to light up for you and then once
you've
figured out who your main characters are
which type your main characters are even
if you have
a couple possibilities like at first
you're not sure
you think derek might be a four or a six
and you play with that for a while
and then usually your understanding of
it will crystallize after a while where
perhaps you see how derek reacts in a
key moment
and that really resonates with a
tendency of a type
six and then you really see yeah i
really think he is a type six not a type
four
so your gra your understanding gradually
crystallizes at first it's tentative and
you keep the possibilities open because
you're not trying to force
any of these types on your characters
you're just trying to
listen to who your characters are and
listen to what the enneagram is
saying as possibilities for them which
type they might be
and so on but after a while you will um
your understanding will crystallize and
at that point it's really interesting to
go to the book the wisdom of the
enneagram
uh which is written by the same guys
from the enneagram institute
and it's a big thick book and there's a
40 page
chapter on each type which takes you
much much
deeper than the one sheet did
and it really goes so deep
into so many aspects of
that character type that it helps you
dimensionalize them
it shows the reasons why these
tendencies are there
and why their fear is there
and the way in which they fall apart
when things
really go bad for them and the way in
which they can
go from being in an extremely unhealthy
reactive state
to a healthy proactive
integration where they they can
pull themselves together and become
a healthy aspect of themselves you know
and scripts deal with character arcs so
where
a person's flaws and weaknesses and
disabilities and all that
are either resolved if there's a
creative resolution and they become a
more healthy version of themselves
or they disintegrate and become
you know fall apart completely
in in a tragic resolution
but the uh the 40 page chapter is
really a deep and complex journey
through the full mechanics of what makes
this person tick
and it really gives you tremendous
depth and dimension and flaws
and strengths and hopes
and subconscious attitudes and
how they react in a bad situation and
how they can
pull themselves out of a tailspin
in certain types of situations so it
really is
very comprehensive and one of the things
that's most interesting about
working with the enneagram is that i've
done it hundreds of times for
so many different characters and
for instance when i'm going through the
40 page chapter
for a character that's maybe a 5 maybe
i've already
done 15 different characters that are
fives and
really studied them in depth and really
know them well
but maybe one was like a serial killer
in you know the bombings of ireland
and one is a you know a
schizophrenic baker in argentina and
like completely a comedy
and so that
the characters come in such completely
different contexts
that when i start going back through
something that i've been through a whole
whole bunch of times
like the 40 page chapter on a type 5
it's like i've never seen it before
because it's completely different
because i'm inhabiting this baker now
instead of this
bomber and it's literally like i've
never seen this stuff before which is
so interesting because i've been soaking
my head in it for
years so it's fresh each time which is
great because
that's what you want when you're
developing characters it's not just
a rehash of people you already know
but a completely fresh discovery from a
completely new character
and you're not only are you
pulling new material out of what you've
already been through
but your facility with the tool grows
and expands each time
so you know you just have more facility
more
ability to understand more complexities
and also the ability to just see it more
simply and clearly like oh it's just
that
instead of like it's all this stuff so
you
you know your your capacity to work with
the tool both
clarifies and deepens into
more complexity because sometimes the
ability to just
see thing clearly and simply is the aha
moment that you've been working toward
maybe for years
in terms of using this tool where you
start to understand
the different personality types
more clearly even if you have to work
hard to get there each time
but you're a little better at it each
time
and yet it's always new that's endlessly
fascinating
okay so that's a good tour through the
enneagram
jeff can you give us an overview of the
36 dramatic situations
the 36 dramatic situations is really a
brainstorming tool
it works with elements
that are common in storytelling
like madness disaster ambition those
types of things
it was created by an italian playwright
named carlo gotzi in the 1700s
and it was endorsed by gerta and
schiller
and on the strength of those
endorsements that hung around for about
150 years
until a guy named george poulty turned
it into a book in 1916
and then it picked up some steam again
but it's
it's unknown by many people and
i've met a lot of people who said they
had the book but could never make heads
or tails out of it
it's it's basically
what ghazi said was that all stories
consist of these
basic 36 human emotional
conflicts and there are things like
ambition
madness conflict with a god the
necessity of sacrificing loved ones
and it's very similar in nature to
the periodic table of elements in
chemistry
where you know carbon hydrogen all that
stuff
so with the periodic table of elements
you could describe anything in this room
quite completely
from one point of view like this table
is carbon
hydrogen oxygen whatever all the
elements that are in it
you can describe it quite completely
from that one point of view
that's only one point of view but that's
getting right at the elements that are
in it
and in storytelling it's the same thing
where you can say
okay this story has madness conflict
with a god
vengeance taken for kindred upon kindred
um and there's different so
different active elements in any given
story
which is useful because it helps you
when you're starting out with a story
where you can
like for instance let's look at your
derek story idea again
so we'd be looking at what would be let
me just get my
book here because
it's easy to go down the one sheet oh
great for these
so here's a list of the
here's a list of the 36 dramatic
situations
just listed simply
so looking at it in terms of derek's
story
so deliverance rescuing or being rescued
crime pursued by vengeance pursuit
disaster revolt daring enterprise the
enigma the riddle or the mystery
obtaining madness he may be like losing
his mind as
being pressed into this dilemma into
like what do i do here
i'm in love with her she's offering me a
life of adventure
but i have to betray my most core values
but
are those core values based on something
that were real or was i snookered into
guarding criminals i don't know i'm
losing my mind
these are all just story possibilities
some of it is like
some of what i was doing were elements
that are already active
in the story idea before it's even
touched
you want to see what you've got it's
like taking inventory
like what are the elements that are
already active in it and there may be
a lot more than you thought there were
which is good
um self-sacrifice for an ideal
all sacrificed for a passion the
necessity of sacrificing loved ones is
going to have to give her up
rivalry of superior and inferior that's
always a good one
because it's so subjective like who's
the superior and who's the inferior
and it's completely point of view
sensitive and it can even flicker back
and forth of who has the upper hand
in any given situation uh discovery of
the dishonor of a loved one if he's
finding out that she
is you know a criminal obstacles to love
is very active in this story but sit
before it's even touched
and enemy loved falling in love with
someone who turns out to be your enemy
or enemy love can be fascination with an
enemy
or coming to understand your enemy
or falling in love with your enemy that
kind of thing
ambition is very central in this story
because
derek is stuck in this rut and he has
ambitions for more but he doesn't know
how to
get there and she may awaken ambition in
him
or he may have a curious lack of
ambition like why don't i care that i'm
stuck in this
rut or why do i not care that she's
dragging me down this
weird road so it can be the
very absence of one of these situations
like you if you look at a character's
ambition it may be that their ambition
is
wildly out of proportion and getting
them in trouble or they could have
utterly no
ambition which is out of proportion for
a given situation it's
curious i'm like why does this person
genuinely not
care which way they go is so it's like
it can be the presence or absence of
these things too
that can be suggestive these are really
suggestive
elements for brainstorming so you can
see that
some of what i'm doing here is as i'm
going down the list and i'm thinking
about this story
it's helping with the what if i'm seeing
what is already there before the story
was ever even touched
the elements that it showed up with and
what if his ambition
to forge a wildly new life
for himself with her is
something that explodes in him like he's
realizing
how dead his life had been before
because he was just
even though he was dissatisfied with the
job in many ways
he was still just nose to the grindstone
numb
plotting ahead and he's like how did i
ever
live like that for years and years i
couldn't go back to another second of
that i'd blow my brains out
it's like yes she's trouble but i can't
go back
to nothing i can't go back to an
emotional vacuum anymore
i kind of stuffed myself into that to
forge ahead but
i don't fit in that room anymore
conflict with a god that's always
interesting because
it doesn't necessarily have to have any
kind of connotation
any kind of religious connotation it
conflict with god suggests a religious
connotation
but it's just any time there's something
going up
against a bigger power it could be you
versus the neighborhood bully
it could be trying to get you know
something
done against city hall
[Music]
so that it's these are very flexible
the less literally you take these the
more actual use you can make
make of them so you want to have a
poetic or metaphoric frame of mind as
you look at these
you don't want to be stuck with their
actual definitions at all
if you look at one of these things even
if it's not a valid
chain of logic that you look at one of
these things and it gives you 10 ideas
those 10 ideas are what's important this
is just a catalyst
in chemistry a catalyst is something
that you throw into a chemical mix and
it creates
a reaction even though the original
catalyst stays the same
so even if this triggers
makes you think of something that
happened to you as a kid which makes you
think of a weird possibility for your
story
which triggers dynamic possibilities for
the ending you've been stuck on
it doesn't matter how this triggered a
chain of thought that got you there
their job is to throw gasoline on the
fire and trigger stuff
and that's that's its only function
really it's just a brainstorming tool
it's just to expose you to the elements
that are already active in your story
even if you hadn't noticed that already
and to expose you to possibilities that
you wouldn't have thought of in 20
lifetimes
things that you never would never have
occurred to you
that all of a sudden are like wow that
could really tweak my third act
i've been dying for something like this
you know it's just like
it's it's throwing hand grenades into
your story idea
erroneous judgment is very central in
this story look how big it is before you
touch anything
because he's like he's looking at her
going
am i crazy or is she like
the most exciting thing in the history
of mankind
or am i like ready for a freaking
straight jacket
and like her too you know it's like i
don't even know which way my head
screwed on anymore
and like the things that i'm
contemplating doing with her and
overturning my job and committing
treason and blah blah it's like
i don't know whether to shoot myself or
run off with her and
have 20 kids like i don't know what i'm
thinking anymore
recovery of a lost one is he going to
get his own
sense of self back loss of loved ones
is he going to lose her is he losing
himself is he losing his sense of honor
so these are like
you want to have a really flexible frame
of mind when you look at them because
you'll get so much more out of them
it's like the wrench doesn't have to fit
the bolt head exactly if it'll turn it
you know even if it kind of fits and
it'll turn it that's all you need you're
just trying to advance your story
or to see more deeply into it because
you're penetrating into the
inner elements that constitute your
story
this tool is really useful
when you're starting a story from
scratch
because say you're
riding on a bus and you hear the two
people in front of you talking and it's
a whacked out conversation and you're
kind of listening in because it's so
interesting and one of them says
something and you're like
that would make an amazing screenplay
holy crap you rush home and you're like
boom oh i gotta you just go on a mile a
minute
that's a great time to go to the 36
dramatic situations
because you're exploding with ideas and
if you look down the list of the 36
you'd be like
that's already in there that's already
in there i didn't know that's in there
but
boy is that potent and
could that be in there that would really
whack it out in a completely dangerous
way or make it more hilarious or
whatever the story is going it's like
god
that is pure dynamite and it's like your
head's already exploding with ideas
and you're tossing explosive elements
you're playing mad scientist
with explosive elements and you may hit
one of them and you're like
that can't be or could it you'd be like
that's scary that's truly terrifying
i i don't even dare think then but you
can't get away from me you're like
okay well what if i did do that you're
like so
it may trigger 100 ideas it's like one
of them can give you a cascade of ideas
like you can barely write them all down
you're already cascading with ideas and
this is throwing gasoline on the fire
you're throwing explosive elements into
the mix playing what if
and so if that one
idea gives you 10 ideas and each of
those gives you 10 ideas
get all that stuff down on paper that's
what's important
that thing doesn't mean anything it just
got you thinking
so it's a extremely valuable
brainstorming tool
in part because you're being exposed to
one complete spectrum of ideas
because where the idea originally came
from gazi said
this these 36 dramatic situations
are every element that is in any story
anywhere
and a lot of people said that's insane i
could come up with way more and they
tried to come up with a list and they
couldn't even get to 24.
they were like actually it's better than
i thought and then schiller and gerta
both said
this is amazing and so it just hung
around
and it's it's just a tool it's just
one complete spectrum of ideas
that you can whip out and use
to trigger ideas for your story and to
see
elements in it that you hadn't noticed
so that
you're going wow this idea was deeper
and more complex than i thought at first
glance
there's more going on there than i
noticed at first
which is great because then you've got
better material
you've got more to work with if you're
doing a tv series you're like exploding
with
seasons and you know cliffhangers
and characters these things can suggest
characters they can suggest resolution
they can complicate dilemmas
but it's just one complete spectrum of
possible ideas
so it's not the be-all and end-all it's
not the only place to look for story
ideas
it's just one tool
and not only is it useful when you're
starting out on an idea
but it's useful to take a quick run
through the one sheet every now and then
just like part way through your script
you may go back and look through it and
go
a crime pursued by vengeance that's
emerging as a much more substantial
aspect to the story
and i hadn't really thought it through
yet but so it can it can just
shake things loose or help you solve
things you've been wrestling with or
expose you to possibilities that might
never have occurred to you
or help you see that this element is
very active in the story if you hadn't
noticed it yet
and then when you get stuck at different
parts of the story where you're really
stuck on your third act or something
going back through it can shake things
loose clarify things
open up possibilities help you see
things that are in it
that you hadn't noticed before that kind
of thing
so it's a it's really an explosive
brainstorming tool
and you want to have broad flexibility
with it a real sense of play
not feel trapped by any of it it doesn't
dictate anything to
you it doesn't say this has to be in
there and
even if at the beginning of the story
you were like wow ambition
is right at the nucleus of this story by
the time you've worked on it for a while
you may
come back and look at it again and be
like ambition doesn't even matter
anymore it's like
i thought that was huge but it's grown
and changed so much
so you're not it's it's just
it's just like getting
blown in the air by explosives at
certain points in the development
process to
shake things loose trigger ideas help
crystallize things clarify things
simplify things complicate things
and that's all part and parcel of the
normal storytelling process
anyway this is just some good chemicals
to throw in there that are like
fertilizer
or clarifying agents or
complicators or clarifiers
so you see it in super clarity all of a
sudden like it can take a while
spend time with the story for quite a
while before you get
true clarity with it like
um sydney pollock when they were working
on tutsi
spent a long time trying to figure out
what the story is really about
and it wasn't until it finally dawned on
him that
becoming a woman made a man out of
michael dorsey
that all of a sudden it like
crystallizes like ah now
i know in really simple terms that's
what the story is about
and he said i went back and looked at
every scene and like how does this scene
work with clarify amplify solidify
the idea that becoming a woman makes a
man out of michael dorsey
and he said it helped a lot in terms of
working with the crew working with the
actors
his own understanding of it and he said
it doesn't mean the story is going to be
good
it just means that i know what it's
about that helps me so much as a
director
i think you've said that the word theme
has been misused extensively
when it comes to film and television but
i believe you've also said that
beware of the with the simple one-liner
yeah it's a theme is something that
is misunderstood by a percentage of
people
uh one of the things that my playwriting
teacher
pointed out to me back when i was
learning this stuff and he
he explained it and then he said this is
really important
make sure you absorb this
and he said the way in which the
protagonist
resolves the dilemma expresses the theme
of the story and
it's very very clear because
the resolution is where the whole story
comes together
and the completion of the story
completes the magic spell on the
audience
which crystallizes the mood that they go
home in
like in a romantic comedy it's been fun
and
fresh but also the romance falling apart
and things
getting troubled and then finally coming
together in the end
and usually you feel happy and in love
at the end if it's done right
and all of that was skillfully
orchestrated by the writer
and the filmmakers and
the theme also comes through that that
which is being
said organically by the story comes
together
in the ending and so if you look at
the protagonist's act of resolution of
the dilemma
and look at the way in which the
protagonist resolves the dilemma
that enables you to put your finger on
the theme so for instance
if you uh let's say
you know you know what if with our story
about derek
that say that
he finds he
creates a third way out of the dilemma
in which he's neither trapped by the
demands of his company nor
by the demands of the blackmailer or
whatever it ends up
being and neither one is a good
way out and by thinking on his feet and
maybe
working with skyler he comes up with a
creative way
to skate through
this horrible trap that he was in
and so if you look at not you look at
what he does but you look at the way in
which he does it
it's about like thinking creatively and
realizing what he really needs in life
where he was always denying his own
needs
and lying to himself and like that he's
finally brutally honest with himself
and is genuinely in love with her even
though
she has betrayed him but she's also been
a victim
and she's changed and he's grown and
he's able to
synthesize a new life for himself
in the process of figuring out how to
get out of the trap that
all of that is what the story is about
thematically it's about creating a new
life for yourself and finding a way out
of hell
and powering out of a skid
and you could see that that
creative type of resolution of taking
command of his life and
powering out of a bad situation
is what the story is about thematically
and what's interesting about
being able to articulate the theme
that's emerging organically from a story
is that
you often only start with a sense of it
like in looking at that type of possible
resolution
for derek i can
see it and sort of talk around it and
describe it in a bunch of different ways
like i just did
like i just said it about 10 different
ways but my
my ability to articulate it crisply and
cleanly
is not there yet because
it you have to live with it for a while
and
look at what the audience leaves with
they leave with a
sense of that theme in their gut in
their soul
and if you stop them on the way out and
ask them to articulate the theme
they probably couldn't they just have it
at a gut level it's in them
so it has a lot to do
you want to be able to dwell with a
partially formed understanding of
something
as a crucial step
in synthesizing your understanding
people are very uncomfortable with
partial solutions
they always want to go no i need to have
the whole thing in my in a nutshell
[Music]
so they don't like partial understanding
it kind of freaks people out
but as a creative writer you need to
get comfortable with that because so
often you're feeling your way through
things
where you're beginning to understand it
at a gut level
but you have no capacity whatsoever at
first for articulating it
and maybe you finally just got a handle
on your theme
and your writing partner comes in the
room and you go like i got it i got it
your writing partner is like so what is
it what is it spit it out and you're
like
i can't yet i got it leave me alone get
out of my face
let me just sit here with it because i
got it and people are feeling creatures
that
long before speech people just
felt animals do that were feeling
creatures
and so the ability to
look at the res look at the the
protagonist's resolution
and look at the way in which he or she
resolves the dilemma
will put you right on the theme that's
actively emerging
from organically in your story and it
may be
diametrically opposed to what you
thought the theme of your story was
going to be
starting with a sense of theme can often
be
troublesome because you can end up being
preachy
and trying to dictate that to the
viewers or the readers
as opposed to that which organically
emerges as the story takes on a life of
its own
the characters take on a life of their
own and you have to be able to
if you're still stuck saying that the
theme
is what you set out to have it be you
may be the one that's missing the boat
the view if the viewers see that movie
they'll get it organically and carry it
away in their gut
and think about it for a while if it's
deep and compelling
and it may affect how they interact with
people for the rest of their lives
like they never yell at their kids again
for the rest of their life or something
like that
because something was awakened in them
even if they can't explain it
maybe maybe later they'll be able to but
the important thing
is that you changed them through
a complete the complete action of a
compelling story
so being able to
have a good strong sense of theme that's
really emerging from your story
is critical because you as the writer
need to be able to
be in touch with the theme that is
coming through the story
if you're still stuck on what you
thought it was going to be then you're
missing the boat
you're missing the chance to work with
the real theme
reinforce it utilize it
and so your story will tend to be weaker
or you're out of touch with what your
story is actually doing
you know it's like you raise your kid
and my kid's going to be a doctor my
kid's going to be a doctor and you still
see that
because you're intent on seeing that but
if you look at the reality of what your
kid is doing you'd be like
he's a jazz musician holy crap i thought
he was a
medical school but no he is genuinely a
jazz musician
so it's about what you want to see
versus what's really there and
theme is huge because
you want to be able to connect
to the theme that's emerging from your
story
reasonably early in the process um
you could see that with the derek's
story i went right to dilemma
and i was all and once i'm working with
dilemma a bit i'm looking ahead to
crisis
because that gives shape and and focus
to the theme the theme is going to
converge at the point of crisis
and force it is decision in action when
there's like
maybe 10 or 15 minutes left in the movie
and then the protagonist
actively resolves the dilemma once and
for all
that's the ending of the story and
then the way in which the protagonist
resolves the dilemma
enables you to put your finger on the
theme that's actively emerging through
that story
and you'll start early in the
development process of your story
but you've already got a tentative
statement or a tentative handle on your
theme
you want to that's why i said beware of
the clever one-liner
because if experts in creativity say
there's often 10
right answers to a question and if you
seize on one of those and say that's the
answer
then you miss out on all the other
layers of complexity
so again it comes back to
people's discomfort with a partially
formed understanding
they it freaks them out to dwell in that
area where they
sort of understand it but not really
but that's the bread and butter of a
writer where you're
gradually morphing through evolving
ideas
and once you can
feel the theme and live with it
and look at all the aspects of
your thought story through the lens of
your
gradually evolving understanding of the
theme
it will inform the whole story
because the theme really is what the
story is about
it's that they call the governing or a
governing idea
or the underlying philosophy of the
story or that which is being said by the
story
and it may be again it may be the
opposite of what you set out to say
or what you even want it to say
but that's what's really coming across
to the audience
and that's price said that
the theme well let me read you this
quote from him
yeah so
so this is price writing in 1908
about playwriting so i was talking about
plays but it's it's exactly the same
stuff
the highest form of play involves the
philosophy of life
so that if the so that if the theme is
not worth considering
there is usually little substance in a
play
with a theme your play will be about
something theme does not stand alone
no principle does mere theme will never
make a play
but it is a definite something it
furnishes a spiritual atmosphere and the
philosophy
of the play it gives the clue to the
actual shaping of the play
the tone depends upon it it is the
largest unit of the play
that's a very interesting statement that
the theme is the largest unit of the
play
that's really interesting for instance
the biggest organ in your body
is your skin
so it's it's that kind of thing the
theme
is is not infects the whole story that's
not the right word but it's
it's spread throughout the whole story
it
determines the shape and the tone of the
story
and all that stuff so it's the ability
to come to grips with it is important
and
gradually as you spend time living with
it your ability to articulate it will be
enhanced
until it kind of crystallizes and then
you're like oh
yeah now i can explain it quite clearly
like sydney pollock could say
the way that becoming a woman made a man
out of michael dorsey
like there's a really crisp clear
statement
of what that story is about thematically
and it and it
helped him so much and it gave a shape
and a tone and
helped him communicate with the actors
and all that stuff
so it's a uh
very powerful aspect of the story
and the basics of it is you don't want
to rush it
let yourself dwell with a partially
formed understanding of it
and it will gradually gel and then
crystallize
but not if you rush it jeff for this
interview you've you've touched on so
many different parts of your
courses in your book i'm wondering if
you can talk a little bit more about
what you will be incorporating into your
what is your two year program
that you've launched okay and and how
that benefits writers
yeah uh it's the same
tools that i've always been teaching but
what i used to do was 30 hour
intensive weekends or 30 hours like
every tuesday night
three hours for 10 weeks and the tools
are complex
and sophisticated so that fire hose
teaching
is not at all the best way to instill
deep know-how with these tools
and i wanted to really
find a much better way to teach
so that i spent a couple years just
thinking about how to
teach it differently and to teach bigger
groups
because it was always limited to six
because i felt like i had to really get
each person using the tool on their own
script
so they could get experience
using the tools properly and see their
stories respond to it
the word of mouth for those classes was
through the roof
because people loved the tools
they got a chance to really use them and
their scripts improved quite a lot
but i felt like they couldn't go home
and use these tools with expertise you
know it's like somebody
teaching you how to build a rocket and
get it to the moon
you have to really study every part of
it and break it down and
integrate it and synthesize it into a
comprehensive expertise
so you know i really studied the science
of learning and
the science of training people and
expertise and
and the science of cognitive
apprenticeship and
found a way to teach a large group of
people
over a much longer amount of time i
found that i could
turn people into seasoned versatile
dramatists who could make scripts work
of any genre
and could tackle any medium
and so you know it's a it's a
high-intensity training program
[Music]
and it's still the hands-on
intensive process that i've always done
but i've opened it up quite a bit
so the core of the program
the one thing that i'm actively doing as
i teach
is an 18-month period
where all we're doing is constantly
working on
maybe six to eight different scripts of
different genres
and at different stages of development
so that one day we'll be working on an
action comedy
the next day it might be a thriller and
so on so we're continually changing
gears and
moving from script to script so you get
you get experience with different genres
and
and even different mediums one will be
for a screenplay one will be a tv series
one will be a stage play
and one of them we're just starting out
one of them is mostly done
and everybody's working as a group and
they're still doing
writing assignments and exercises and
learning games
and there's like group problem solving
like if we're
stuck at the end of
you know a thriller trying to figure out
how the murder actually goes down
maybe we'll spend a whole week on it and
are completely stumped
and so we have group problem solving
where
i'll have everybody coming up with ideas
that you know like their assignment
would be to go home and come up with 20
different ways
to pull off this murder and then look at
your 20 ideas
and sort the best ones to the top and
then
put those best ones into the group and
then everybody works together to sort
those best ones to the top so we may end
up with
20 or 30 phenomenal ideas the best of
the best
and we all look at those and go wow
these are really great
this one could really solve our problem
this one solves it and opens up an
interesting stuff that would
make us complicate the story earlier on
it like opens up a whole lot
more this one is so good we should set
it over here and make a whole script out
of it on its own
but it makes the students do the work
themselves
it's not about them sitting back and
watching me do this stuff
it's about me making them as proactive
as possible
so that the more expertise they acquire
the more they're
integral integral to the process so that
if we come to like a horror film
that's partly developed there might be a
team of advanced students
who are actively working on that every
day and we say like oh so how's it going
in there say well we solved this
now we're stuck here we use this tool
and so and so came up with this
phenomenal idea and it's
it's fun and we're doing great but we're
stuck here and then
everybody is participate on that as a
group
and there might be a teaching moment
where i end up giving a whole lecture on
this
particular aspect of one tool
and that teaching lecture becomes part
of the permanent teaching library
that anybody can go to at any time
and i'm basically
turning these students into rough and
tumble
experts who can really tackle anything
sometimes i feel like i'm training them
to be like rodeo clowns or something
because i don't know if you know this
but rodeo clowns are
high skilled gymnasts they're like
really really
technically proficient and really i mean
they go up against a sixteen hundred
pound bull
to distract it to rescue the rider and
like they like
grab a fence and leap and they're like
unbelievably skilled and rough and ready
and can
tackle anything and and so it's like
that kind of
versatility and flexibility and attack
and
high degree of skill in multiple highly
technical tools
and you can throw them into a comedy or
a horror film
or a thriller and they're like i got
this
and that's what i'm that's what they're
all building toward
and so really i only do one thing and
that's
this open workshop where we're
constantly building
scripts and that's all we're doing and
that's how i train people
and there's definitely teaching moments
here and there
as they come up but it's about learn by
doing it's a real apprenticeship we're
really building real scripts in real
time
and the challenge that i had when i
when i when i was wrestling with how do
i teach larger groups and teach
differently the question that finally
freed me up was okay so
if i could wave a magic wand and teach
any way i wanted to
what would i do instead of stuck in all
the limits and how do i get out of this
it was like no no no
if i just could wave a magic wand and do
anything no
limits no anything i was like okay well
i'd take
two years and really train the crap out
of them like really train them
and then okay so if it's a two-year
program
how do i make it so the big question was
how do i make it so people can join in
because that you know it's like you hear
about the program and i want to join
them and i'm sorry
it's another 14 months before the next
one starts that doesn't work
so i was like okay so how can it be a
continuously ongoing
open workshop where we're just building
scripts all the time
how do i make it so anybody can join in
at any time so i said okay so
if there was a three-month training
program that's basically
a pre-recorded video program
and it's the building of a complete
script in those three months
it's kind of like a a flight simulator
where you take this
three-month video program and i start on
day one with a one sentence idea for a
thriller
and we're by the end of the day one
we've already got an idea up and running
we're looking at her dilemma already
and then and they have exercises and
learning games and assignments
but not too much but it's it's intensive
and then day two
we're building more and it's all me on
video talking to them
but i'm giving them assignments and
trying to make them as proactive as
possible
and they're copying down the use of the
tools and learning how to think
and seeing and and participating in the
creation of this story
and even though they can't participate
in the actual creation of it because
that three-month class may have been
recorded two years ago
i still give them professional
assignments say okay so
she's stuck in this room and this person
is watching her but she's got to get a
message to so and so or she's dead
i don't know how to do that your
assignment is go home and come up with
20 different
ways she might do that and i'll show up
the next day with my solution for that
and i can't interact with what they did
because this was recorded years ago
but they had to really wrestle with the
problem and really
think it through so i'm trying to make
them as
proactive and as involved in the process
as possible
and as we use all the tools and they end
up hand copying all the sequence
proposition plot we do as
we construct it and then once we've done
it
we've done it for the overall story
they've hand copied that done a free
check they've hand copied that
just a few pages each day due to all the
sequences
and then we come to the first scene and
we structure that scene
and they actually write that scene
and then the next day we structure the
next scene and they write that scene
we go all the way through and they each
person writes their own version of this
thriller
and when that's when they've got their
own version that graduates them into the
18-month program
so it's a way to give them enough
exposure
to the process see all the tools in
action they're not
tasked with trying to learn the tools
their main job is to observe everything
it's to get oriented so they see the
whole process
and then when i'm training them
intensively in the 36
dramatic situations and they're like i
hate this why is he having us do this
over and over again
they're not going i hate this they're
going oh i see how immensely valuable it
is
because we did it there and so
not only are they oriented and they've
seen the whole thing so they understand
how each part
functions as part of the whole but when
they come out of that three-month video
recording program
they can jump into the 18-month program
and we may be spending
the whole week figuring out the ending
of a romantic comedy
and they can jump right in they know
they understand sequence proposition
plot dilemma all these things
it's not foreign to them so they can
jump right in and participate so that
means
in this ongoing 18-month thing they can
join in at any time
and then as they acquire more and more
expertise
and i give more and more responsibility
to them
and challenge them more and they're
always have to be able to articulate
their thinking process
as they wrestle with the tools so that
the experts
toward the end of the 18 months i can
say to them
as they're wrestling with the ending of
a ghost story
i'd say okay so articulate what you're
thinking and they'd be like well okay so
we have a good strong dilemma but we're
still struggling with the crisis we have
this this and this for the crisis
and i'd say have you thought of that and
they'd be like good point they'd throw
they're not thrown
or i'd say like wait you did that wrong
and they're like
well so what i'd be like this this and
they go oh of course
like they're they're almost there you
know they're like and everybody's
learning from that
and and the more and more expertise them
the more they don't
need me my instructional voice is
internalized into their own process
they can emulate my thinking process
they can emulate
they have the metacognitive skills to
evaluate their own
professional process so they can be like
i'm doing the technique
properly but i shouldn't even be
focusing on that because
here's the main question so to be able
to challenge their own
professional skills and kick themselves
out of bed and
reverse their own trajectory and all
that
is important then in order to graduate
from the program
they do the last three months which is
to build a script
on their own still in this open workshop
and we've been throwing ideas that
people don't so much care about into the
group's story band
and even working on them so they pick an
idea from the group's story bin
develop it build it
in an open workshop that's open to
everybody and it's like a teaching
hospital where i'll come by with the
whole group and go
how's it going where are you at and
they'd be like well i solved this oh
that's great that was a hard hump to get
over and they like
tell me about it and this is the tool
i'm using now
here's where i'm stuck i may have some
insight or i might say wow that's
brilliant
and the other students may have
questions and they're articulating their
thought process
and when they complete that script they
can graduate and they take that script
with them it's theirs
or they could if they want more they can
do another one like that or they can
also
stay in the group and they may like
collaborating with the people they've
been through with and they can be in
private sessions where they still have
this as like their writer's group and a
coffee shop and they have people who can
read their drafts and
brainstorm with them so that that kind
of
interactive capability with people who
know the same tools is there for
graduates
and it's it's not open to the other
people because they want to be really
working their scripts now
but they may like the the community so
that's an option too
so it's really the 18-month there's
three months to get into it it's kind of
like if you're going to go up and work
on the space station
nasa will put you through a training and
then you can go up on the space station
you're not going to get people killed
and you can operate in zero g
and you know know how to function in an
emergency and all that stuff
and then the last three months you do it
all on your own which
completes this the synthesis of all your
skills
and your abilities and your you know
your your functionality
to where you feel like you can go off
and do your own thing or stick around
and
keep working with you know the same
community
in a private format that's not open to
the whole group but you can still
interact with people
so that's the basics of it
it's been fun to create it's been really
challenging
and just trying to figure out all the
things and integrate all the
new learning techniques that i've found
and
keep challenging myself and it's been
still is i'm still in the middle of
creating it and it's
it's fascinating again it was i got
burnt out on teaching the same thing
non-stop for 18 years it was really good
to get a break and now it's really fun
to come back into it